when an anomaly is first detected by an
scp foundation field agent it's up to
the foundation's mobile task forces to
tag and bag the impossible entities
before they can do any more harm
sometimes these retrievals are
uneventful other times
not so much
especially when they're dealing with
brutal forces of nature like scp-096
also known as the shy guy a creature
that from the very first interaction
with the foundation
had a reputation for being dangerous and
needed to be feared
a series of vague sightings and
mysterious disappearances up in the
frosty mountains of the yukon first
sparked the foundation's interest when
they were certain that they had an
anomaly on their hands two retrieval
teams zulu9a and zulu9b were dispatched
to secure and contain the entity
zulu9a took the lead in a heavy duty
chopper equipped with 50 caliber gau-19
heavy machine guns and carrying an at4
anti-tank launcher they were prepared
for anything or so they thought as they
established a visual on
scp-096 while two clicks away from the
target they couldn't get a clear line of
sight on the creature but it appeared to
be stationary docile and was making no
attempt to flay a piece of cake right
little did they know that
scp-096 was just looking away from them
if it was facing towards them it'd be a
whole different horror story as zulu9a
were about to find out the team landed
their helicopter next to the creature
and were shocked to see that it was
completely naked in spite of the
sub-zero temperatures all around them
the creature was unnaturally thin as
though it had been starved for weeks
with bone white skin and unnaturally
long limbs the team guessed that the
creature's arms must have been at least
1.5 meters long but its docile nature
and insubstantial body mass gave the
impression that it wouldn't prove too
difficult to contain that is
until they saw its face
zulu9a's captain was the lone survivor
of the incident as he was lucky enough
to be looking away when the creature
turned towards his team the rest of the
squad ended up staring eye to eye with
scp-096
and from that moment on wasn't docile
anymore the creature began to whimper
then cry then sob uncontrollably in a
way that sounded eerily human this
sudden change in temperament startled
the rest of zulu 9a and they opened fire
on the creature under the hail of
gunfire
scp-096 entered a murderous frenzy and
began tearing into the hapless squad of
soldiers while its flesh and organs did
seem to take damage as a result of the
barrage of 50 caliber rounds from the
helicopter-mounted machine guns
its skeletal structure remained intact
and it continued its onslaught tearing
the team limb from limb even after they
blown practically all the flesh from the
creature
the at4 anti-tank launcher proved
equally ineffective at stopping scp-096
while it was in attack mode
it was only after slaughtering the
entire team that it returned to its
docile state nobody knows exactly what
the creature did to zulu 9a after the
gunfire started but no trace of the team
was left behind
zulu 9b touched down soon after and with
a grave warning from the captain not to
look at the creature's face they were
finally able to subdue it a bag was
placed over scp-096's face which seemed
to soothe it enough to move it to a
nearby foundation facility little did
they know they just obtained one of the
deadliest scps of all time and while it
may have been under lock and key for now
it seemed inevitable that it would get
out and cause more violence and chaos
research and containment procedures for
the scp-096 were put under the command
of dr dan a senior researcher at the
site it was his job to find out exactly
what this being was capable of the more
he tested the more he realized that they
were dealing with something truly
terrifying disposable d-class personnel
were used to figure out exactly what it
was that caused the creature to enter
its attack mode
just as it had during the initial
retrieval mission
scp-096 went berserk when any of the
attending personnel saw its face in this
stage it would enter a period of
considerable and unstoppable distress
for one to two minutes covering its face
and wailing loudly when the period of
distress ended the creature would
mercilessly slaughter every d-class that
had seen its face and just like with
zulu9a no trace of their bodies would be
left behind
dr den was horrified and intrigued by
this phenomenon the creature killed
anyone that saw its face directly but
could the same be said for indirect
depictions of the creature's face
such as images and videos
dr dan was desperate to find out more
d-class personnel were brought in to
test this to frightening results dr dan
found that the creature did indeed still
enter attack mode when people saw
pictures and videos of
scp-096's face the creature seemed to
have an innate sense of when people were
viewing these representations even when
it should have had no conceivable way of
knowing it didn't matter how far away or
how many barriers were in place between
the viewer and the creature the attack
mode would still activate and once it
did it seemed as though nothing could
stop the creature from hunting down the
one who saw its face with all this new
data special containment procedures were
devised to keep the creature safely
under lock and key its cell was a five
meter by five meter by 5 meter airtight
steel cube
fitted with advanced pressure sensors
and laser detectors to ensure that
scp-096 remained in its cell without
risking anyone having visual contact
with the creature's face all cameras and
video equipment were strictly forbidden
and weekly checks for any cracks or
holes in the containment cell were
mandatory
of course none of this would stop the
creature if anyone somehow saw its face
in order to solve that little problem dr
dan would need to continue his research
to find a method of subverting the
creature's deadly glance they needed to
know exactly what they were dealing with
but how could they when even a glance at
a photo or video of the being meant
certain death
a potential solution was proposed
creating an artistic representation of
the creature's face something that
hadn't yet been attempted but how would
they achieve such a fee simple they'd
procure a d-class prisoner with some
artistic talent
and they found one who had been a tattoo
artist before becoming a foundation
guinea pig
dr dan formulated an ingenious plan for
keeping this d-class alive for long
enough to accurately draw an image of
scp-096's face
he would be placed in a bathysphere
diving bell several kilometers
underwater and tens of kilometers away
from the containment cell where the scp
was being held the d-class was made to
look at a photograph of the creature's
face and then replicate that image in a
pencil sketch
dr dan first confirmed that the
creature's attack mode is only activated
by the creature's face by having the
d-class look at a series of photos of
the scp's body parts one by one finally
finishing with its face the d-class
began drawing and even remarked on how
creepy the scp's facial features were
despite not knowing the deadly context
meanwhile back in its containment cell
scp-096
sent someone viewing its face and
entered its inconsolable crying state
followed by its attack mode it broke out
of containment easily and began making a
b-line for the d-class traversing the
miles between it and its prey the
d-class didn't know it as he locked the
finished drawing into a separate
autonomous submersible but he was
already dead as the drawing made its way
up to a researcher on the surface
scp-096 dived into the water and started
swimming down towards the artist minutes
later the bathysphere was breached
and the d-class was torn to shreds
scp-096 was recaptured without issue by
surface recovery team foxtrot 303a and
further testing on the drawing showed
that artistic representations of
scp-096's face were in fact harmless
from this experience
we now know that the creature has a
gaunt face with totally white eyes
possibly indicating blindness and a
grossly extended jaw nevertheless dr dan
was adamant that scp-096 was too
dangerous to be left alive and requested
permission from the upper echelons of
the foundation to terminate the creature
by any means necessary however the
doctor's request would fall on deaf ears
until
it all started with a seemingly innocent
image
while it's now been redacted for your
safety the black speck inside the yellow
circle was once a minuscule image of
scp-096
taken unknowingly in the 1990s by a
semi-professional mountaineer one day
they were looking at old photographs
when his eyes passed over the tiny speck
without even noticing that he had seen
anything but scp-096 noticed and began
entering its attack mode it tore through
its steel containment unit like tissue
paper causing the release of a nerve
agent that killed a number of attending
foundation staff the monster then fled
the base and began pursuing its prey
with mobile task force tau one in hot
pursuit dr olixi who was helping to
manage the site where the scp was
contained was in dismay over the
situation dr dan was out of the country
at the time trying to discover more
about the creature's origins however he
did leave the mobile task force with a
new secret weapon against the rampaging
shy guy
project scramble scramble were
state-of-the-art goggles featuring a new
technology created by dr dan which using
artistic renditions of 096's facial
features could detect and scramble the
features of scp-096 into an
unrecognizable form preventing the
normally deadly effect of gazing upon
its face
in theory this would allow mtf tal1 to
engage safely with 096 once its prey had
been eliminated and bring it back into
containment but disaster struck on two
fronts first the prey in question was
located in a population center creating
the potential for a huge loss of life
and the second bigger problem was that
the scramble technology didn't work as
stray pixels of the creature's face
would reach the eyes of the task force
before the internal microprocessor had
time to scramble them the mission turned
into a death sentence as scp-096
slaughtered almost the entire task force
as well as a number of civilians in town
including an infant and its entire
family it was a monumental disaster made
even worse by a final revelation dr dan
and dr alexi had themselves facilitated
the entire containment breach and
allowed the resulting massacre to happen
with dr dan hoping it would be enough
motivation for foundation command to
green light his research into destroying
the creature
anything that would give him the
opportunity to kill this thing would be
worth the bloodshed his plan worked and
the scp foundation saw it his way
approving his request to neutralize
scp-096
however success comes at a cost for dr
dan once he figures out a way to finally
kill the creature
though done in his line of duty he
himself will be terminated by the
foundation for his crimes against
humanity but considering how much damage
scp-096 is capable of causing if it ever
got to a major population center or even
worse was ever caught on camera and
broadcast to a worldwide audience the
doctor himself would likely deem his own
death a justifiable cause
to this day the foundation is
researching ways to kill the creature
and they're still looking for their
silver bullet
and the pressure is on they hadn't known
about the seemingly innocent picture
that sparked the last containment breach
the one taken decades ago in which the
shy guy had only occupied four tiny
pixels four tiny pixels that resulted in
multiple innocent lives lost
so be careful where you look because who
knows how many other photos of the
creature are lurking out there photos
with an innocent dot in the background
your eyes glance over it not even
noticing the little blip
until you hear a distant wailing that
seems to be getting closer and closer
and closer
and then it's already too late
well hello there scp fans let's get this
out of the way first you've seen the
title and thumbnail and you're probably
wondering wait is siren had an scp and
the answer is no
siren head is not an scp it's a freaky
internet monster created by renowned
canadian horror artist trevor henderson
your next question is probably what's
with this crazy looking server bank
behind me allow me to introduce you to
the anomatron 6000 the latest
advancement of supercomputing owned and
operated exclusively by the scp
foundation it's capable of a whole bunch
of interesting features calculating
ideal containment methods running state
of the art foundation webcaller software
making and editing fun scp youtube
videos but the most interesting feature
that the anomatron has to offer is
running hyper advanced simulations
regarding all things anomalous with data
fed into it by thousands of real-life
experiments conducted by the scp
foundation it's going to save countless
dollars and lives for foundation
researchers but way more importantly
it's going to let us explore all kinds
of weird and wacky what-if scenarios
that would never happen organically
could scp-343 beat goku or superman
who's a deadlier supernatural killer
or freddy krueger would the world simply
explode from adorableness if scp-999 and
baby yoda ever cross those multiversal
barriers and met we can explore all of
these questions along with any others
you may have down in the comments
seriously comment it we dare you but to
get things started we figured we'd make
the anomatron pit the foundation's
lankiest nightmare monster
scp-096 against the internets trevor
henderson's siren head sorry slenderman
you're just not cool anymore so without
further ado let's kick the anomatron
into gear and see how this wild battle
plays out it's time for
scp-096 vs siren head ricky and elliott
a pair of aspiring travel youtubers from
california were taking a vacation to the
pacific northwest to spend some time in
the area's beautiful lush forests
however while the duo were both big fans
of travel for its own sake they weren't
just here for the trees and fresh air
you see despite their jet-setting
lifestyle ricky and elliot's subscribers
and views hadn't exactly been phenomenal
lately turns out hiking vlogs and gopro
footage of the two of them jumping into
absurdly blue water and bali weren't
exactly that interesting to people who
weren't actually there but ricky had
formulated an ingenious plan to pull the
two of them out of obscurity they would
hunt down and film real footage of the
legendary siren head a supernatural
monster said to haunt forests and
isolated graveyards there were plenty of
fakers out there on youtube but if the
two of them could get real footage of
siren head and also preferably survive
the experience they'd be framing their
golden play buttons in no time but they
were already encountering certain issues
for starters the two californians had
severely underestimated just how cold it
was in the pacific northwest and as such
were already shivering from bone deep
cold the second issue was food while the
two of them had thought ahead and
brought a selection of tasty protein
bars they'd also gotten hungry during
the early hours of their wok and eaten
all of them leaving them feeling
severely out of luck by the time dinner
rolled around and the third and perhaps
most problematic issue of all was the
fact that ricky and elliot didn't
exactly have a great sense of direction
during all of their previous trips
they'd been on guided tours with local
experts in this instance wanting to take
all the siren head glory and clout for
themselves they decided to come in alone
with the incredibly janky google maps
app to guide them as such as the night
was creeping in the two aspiring youtube
celebrities had no idea where they were
needless to say it wasn't exactly an
ideal situation and to make matters
worse ricky and elliot had been
experiencing some strange feelings for
the last couple of hours when they'd
gotten particularly deep into the forest
that dread-inducing sensation of being
watched by something lurking just out of
sight a gaze with some unknowable and
darkly malicious intent boiling behind
it these two poor saps had no idea what
was in store for them tonight and
wouldn't you know it the one watching
them right now wouldn't even be the only
monster after them after an expectable
amount of bumbling and buffoonery ricky
and elliot managed to gather up enough
tinder to make a semi-respectable
campfire they could sleep out here
tonight then set off in search of siren
head or civilization whichever came
first in the daylight the next day the
duo did what they could to remain
chipper in spite of the ominous
circumstances sure they were trapped in
the depths of the woods alone but think
of the amazing vlog footage they'd get
they'd be like the next blair witch crew
except they'd live hopefully but as the
duo sat next to their campfire they felt
that ominous sensation again the hairs
on the back of their necks started
standing up they felt shivers that
didn't just come from the cold more and
more they started to feel certain that
something in this forest was watching
them something ancient and powerful and
evil that's when they heard the
tell-tale crackle of radio static and
their skeletons almost jumped out of
their skin could it be him the patron
saint of gone missing without a trace of
creeping dread of bad things coming
siren head himself both men fell silent
all they could hear was the crackling of
their own fire had the sound before just
been an illusion a product of a pair of
paranoid mines also predisposed to sense
siren-headed monsters lurking amongst
the trees they'd been reading about a
higher rate of disappearances in this
area along with a number of frightening
sightings of tall thin beings and radio
static that seemed perfectly consistent
with siren head activity that's why
they'd come here in the first place but
had they come here to their deaths the
two needed to distract themselves or
they'd go mad from the paranoia they
decided to share a few fun little
anecdotes of the travels they'd had
before meeting one another showing the
photos they'd saved on their smartphones
ricky had been to hawaii tahiti bora
bora fiji saint lucia and the maldives
clearly he liked his vacations warm and
sandy elliott on the other hand tended
to like his trips to be a little more
adventurous he'd seen volcanoes
waterfalls deep and treacherous cave
systems and of course a little guided
mountaineering one photo that elliot
showed ricky was particularly
breathtaking he was standing in the
foreground of a snowy landscape with an
incredible mountain range behind him
when ricky asked elliott where exactly
he'd taken this picture strangely enough
he drew a complete blank maybe somewhere
in canada or siberia or something like
that but it was a hell of a trip
whatever the case he remembered having a
great time it was such a tiny detail but
when looking at the photo ricky couldn't
help but notice something in the
background a speck of white sure not
exactly newsworthy in the snowy mountain
range but this wasn't snow it was a
speck of white that seemed to be a
slightly different shade than the rest
of the mountain strange perhaps it was
just some tiny particles stuck on the
lens whenever the photo was taken the
two continued to chat and warmed their
hands against the fire having no idea of
the horror they just awoken in doing so
over a hundred miles away at an scp
foundation containment site researchers
and guards walked around the perimeter
of a huge airtight metal cube reading
off diagnostics and audio recordings for
reasons that should be obvious to
everyone who's a fan of this channel
there were no camera feeds coming from
the inside of the great metal cube only
a faint whimpering sound like a sad
wounded animal and the clanking of
pacing feet moving back and forth over
the metal dragging forlorn knuckles it
turned every head in the room when the
crying started to get louder soon it
wasn't just quiet weeping it was a
series of horrendous slobbering sobs
whales of pure pain and despair someone
in the room screamed close your eyes and
hit the deck knowing exactly what had
happened they learned well enough from
the infamous incident
096-1-8 containment breach that there
was no way of stopping this thing until
it run its course the best they could do
was minimize their own fatalities in the
process everyone in the room did as they
were told hitting the ground closing
their eyes and covering them with their
hands just to be safe that's when the
solid steel of the cube was torn open
like crepe paper and the howling raging
scp-096 broke free galloping on all
fours through the nearest wall
shattering it and spraying debris
everywhere as mobile task forces were
dispatched to track the rampaging
abomination and try their best to clear
the path ahead as it sought out its
target one thought was going through the
minds of everyone in the room woe
bettered the poor fools who saw that
monster's face back in the deep dark
forests of the pacific northwest the
presence of some unnerving force was
becoming far harder to deny for ricky
and elliot they heard the sounds of
garbled voices out in the woods the
squeals and crackles of radio static
they saw shapes moving amongst the trees
tall and thin like long spindly limbs
while neither wanted to voice their fear
they were both thinking similar things
if there really was a monster out here
why hadn't it killed them it had all the
time in the world to do it but that was
just it wasn't it it had all the time in
the world so why rush it had every
advantage it could take its time and do
this exactly how it wanted to ricky and
elliot had made themselves the perfect
prey and as they saw a huge lith figure
suddenly separate itself from the trees
they began to wonder if it was really
worth it to risk both of their lives for
youtube clout either way it was now
probably too late for regrets ricky and
elliot's jaws fell in horror as the
monster emerged from the darkness before
them they recognized the awful mottled
skin stretched over the monster's
40-foot frame they saw the grasping
hands and up above the nightmarish
faceless head split into a pair of
sirens pointing in different directions
each one filled with gnashing teeth and
slithering tongues it was even more
terrifying than they could possibly have
imagined saren had speakers crackled
into life and hissed out
ricky and elliot stumbled backwards as
siren head advanced its speakers still
bleeding hateful static neither could
move or speak only watch as its long
gnarled fingers reach from the dark to
grasp them there was a terrible pained
whale in the woods after that but it
wasn't coming from ricky elliot or siren
head it was distant at first but soon
became louder and louder as the force's
point of origin came barreling towards
them even siren head couldn't help but
turn to see scp-096
a flash of terrible white fury come
charging towards them in the dark
knocking down all the trees in its path
leaves and pine needles scattered trunks
exploded into splinters nothing would
stop the shy guy from claiming its prey
nothing would stop it from destroying
ricky and now as it approached elliot
made the fatal mistake of looking at its
face too 096 lunge ready to go in for
the kill when siren head's hands closed
around the shy guy's slender torso in
one fluid motion with surprising
strength for its scrawny build it hurled
the shy guy into the distance smashing
another several trees in its path the
words
hissed out of its speakers but 096 was
only down for mere moments it sprung
back up on its hind and four legs and
started galloping towards ricky and
elliot again who were still frozen in
place this time just before the shy
guy's terrible claws could close around
the two hapless wannabe youtubers down
came siren head's clenched fist pounding
096's head into the dirt
overhead mobile task force helicopters
circled wearing their scrambled goggles
and trying to get a visual on the
situation unfolding below they could
hardly believe what they were seeing
down there was some other unclassified
anomaly managing to intercept 096 in its
rage state only a handful of anomalies
on record have ever been shown of being
capable of such a feat it seemed that
they were dealing with something serious
here down below the battle continued
siren head had a unique advantage over
most other combatants facing scp-096
it was an extra-dimensional being with
no eyes merely an innate psychic
awareness of its victims around it not
unlike how scp-096 detect people seeing
its face in photographs or videos
without need for any kind of direct
contact as such it was impossible for
siren head to see the shy guy's face and
thus impossible for the shy guy to ever
actually direct its aggression against
it whether or not 096 would kill steel's
siren head's intended prey was another
matter entirely in the night's first
minor miracle ricky and elliot
remembered that they'd been born with
working legs and decided that right now
would be an excellent time to use them
they turned and began to run while siren
head continued beating the shy guy into
the dirt sprinting with all their might
however the growing distance between
them only aggravated the shy guy further
it sprang out from the dirt with
unstoppable force and broke away from
siren head's grip the shy guy never
wasted time ever it always made a
beeline for its intended victim with one
directive in mind total annihilation
tonight is no different ricky and elliot
screamed as they heard its pounding
gallop on the ground behind them closer
closer closer then suddenly defying all
spatial reasoning siren had emerged out
from the darkness between ricky elliott
and 096 being 40 feet tall siren had
dwarfed even the shy guy it lunged and
grabbed the wailing white monstrosity
holding it as one would a particularly
vicious cat and trying to keep it in
place siren had wanted to crush the
monster's bones and carry on stalking
its feeble human prey who were currently
in the process of getting away but
somehow that was impossible it was
almost like the monster had an
indestructible skeleton up above the
multiple task forces continued observing
this clash of the titans from their two
helicopters seeing how siren head was
somehow doing a serviceable job of
subduing the shy guy one of the task
force members joked maybe we should hire
this guy another chimed in i don't think
we have any ballistic vests in his size
the laughter soon turned to screams when
siren had hurled 096's flailing body up
at one of the helicopters with
incredible force knocking it out of the
sky it greened down to the ground a ball
of fear and violence before exploding
anyone who survived the initial blast
was unlucky enough to have seen the shy
guy's face their screams rang out
briefly before being abruptly silenced
by the monster helicopter alpha had no
survivors meanwhile ricky and elliot had
kept running until their lungs burned
and their muscles pumped thumbtacks
seeing that the chaos was so far behind
them now they took a moment to stop and
breathe recomposing themselves in the
second minor miracle of the night it
looked like the two of them had actually
survived this ordeal those two horrific
monsters had canceled each other out but
ricky and elliot were about to learn a
harsh lesson they really weren't that
lucky the last thing the two of them
ever saw was siren head emerging from
the darkness once more the last thing
they ever felt was the monster's
terrible gnarled fingers curling around
their bodies too fast for them to escape
and the last thing they ever heard was
each other's screams followed by a
sickeningly meaty crunch elsewhere in
the forest
scp-096's wales died down to its usual
mudlin saab the rage state had ended all
of its targets had been destroyed it
just hadn't been the one to do all the
destroying per se not long after that
helicopter bravo descended safely and
the remaining mtf members closed around
the blubbering beast someone black
bagged it and everyone breathed a sigh
of relief knowing that was at least one
monster taken care of tonight what about
the other one the mtf lieutenant asked
the team's commander shook his head and
said ah let's worry about that freak
later and get 096 back to containment
this place gives me the creeps this
video is about two things the first is
scp-096
also known as the shy guy a horrific
monster who murders anyone and anything
unfortunate enough to look at its face
directly or through photos or videos the
second is you because we asked you for
your favorite questions theories and
hypothetical situations involving 096.
we even asked if you thought someone
would be safe from 096 on the moon and
you delivered if you haven't watched our
first video on the infamous shy guy we
recommend checking that out first but
feel free to stick around even if you
haven't first of all let's take a look
at the questions you had about the scp
foundation's most dangerous introvert
and see if we can't find some answers
how close would you have to be to
trigger it like if it was 5 kilometers
away would it still count the short
answer is that 096's homicidal rage can
be triggered from pretty much any
distance we'll get into some of the
potentially crazy extents of this later
on but if you see the shy guy's face
while you're sharing a dimension with
him you're in serious trouble people who
viewed the creature's face in different
countries or even miles underwater have
met gruesome ends five kilometers would
definitely not keep you safe what were
his origins and how strong is he
compared to scp-682
the origins of
scp-096 are still shrouded in mystery
all we know for sure is that he was
discovered by the foundation in a snowy
mountainous region as for physical
durability he's about even with 682 as
both survived their encounter we know
682 has the psychological advantage
though as 096 has been terrified of the
lizard ever since they met in cross
testing however you could argue that 096
is technically more dangerous since
unlike 682 096 has never been pacified
before killing its intended target while
on a rampage if he goes into an
unstoppable attack mode when someone
sees his face shouldn't you not show his
face in the thumbnail thankfully
according to the official documents
artistic representations like paintings
or digitally drawn youtube thumbnails
have no effect only actual photographs
or videos of the creature can be deadly
so you're safe unless we decide to do a
096 face reveal to celebrate our next
100 000 subscribers of course this leads
us to our next question if it attacks
you when you look at it then how did the
scientist draw the picture of the thing
without looking at it that's a good
question and also one that occurred to
the foundation scientists who came up
with an extremely elaborate solution
they put a d-class tattoo artist inside
a diving bell miles underwater and had
him unseal a photograph of the creature
before drawing a copy this copy was then
released from the diving bell in a
sealed container before 096 inevitably
got to the poor d-class does the shy guy
have to be viewed through a good quality
image to enter a rage state
unfortunately
no
even the most poorly rendered or
minuscule image of 096's face is a death
sentence one of the most infamous
incidents resulted from a man seeing a
small dot that was only a few pixels
wide in a photo from an old ski trip the
dot was 096 taken from a mile away no
true image of 096 is safe regardless of
size in some canons despite 096 being
referred to as indestructible the
foundation managed to terminate it after
many attempts and even more bureaucracy
how did they do it well a lot of 096's
body has been blown away by conventional
arms fire its hyper tough skeleton is
what has given it such an indestructible
reputation in one tale though foundation
researchers actually used this to their
advantage and employed the use of the
neck snapping killer sculpture scp-173
after using 173 to damage 096's bones
powerful acid was injected into the
skeleton destroying it from within
though of course this isn't the official
ending of the 096 story because the scp
foundation doesn't have a single
unifying cannon that's enough questions
now it's time for you to school us let's
look at some of your favorite theories
about the shy guy starting with i
sometimes like to imagine that 096 is
nice but he can't control when someone
sees him and after he kills the person
he starts to cry because he didn't want
to kill them there is actually some
evidence to suggest that scp-096
might not want to kill a great example
of this is its cross test with
scp-978 a camera which reveals the
deepest desires of whoever or whatever
is in its photos the photo it took of
096 showed that it had completely
disappeared from the photo showing its
deepest desire was to just be invisible
and unseen maybe it wants to disappear
because it doesn't want to hurt anybody
regarding the moon question i think
scp-096 would probably stay in that
hostile state until you came back at
which point it would promptly rip you to
shreds and do whatever it does to your
mutilated corpse based on what we know
about prior 096 incidents this feels
incredibly likely it's also possible
that it might enter its docile state
before becoming aggressive again when
you return to its murder range you
really don't want to find out either way
he can just jump to the moon easy he
does squats and containment all the time
while it's scrawny physique doesn't make
it seem like 096 understands the concept
of exercise there aren't any cameras in
096's cell so technically we can't prove
it isn't doing squats to pass the time
in there i really doubt a blind person
would be safe from his effect since 096
has the iq of a newborn baby i think he
will count it as looking at him this is
an interesting theory however seeing as
096 is able to sense when people see its
face from entire continents away the way
it knows if you can see its face might
be a little more psychic in nature
therefore it's probable that it wouldn't
mistakenly kill someone who hasn't
actually seen its face such as a person
who is blind to deal with him in my
opinion simply frees him either in space
or in the mountains his body shuts down
and when looked at it it will not react
correctly it is simply asleep while we
don't know how
scp-096 would react to a zero-g
environment for a creature that's always
nude it seems extremely tolerant to the
cold when it was first found it was
lurking in icy mountains and a
foundation agent commented on the fact
it wasn't even shivering despite the
incredibly low temperatures but who
knows if there's a temperature out there
that's too low even for the shy guy if
someone looks at it in china and it's in
the u.s then you get on its back you'll
get a free piggyback ride to china it's
a free trip to china and all it costs is
a human life that's my theory
technically it'd be at the cost of two
human lives unless you wore a diving
suit with plenty of oxygen 096 has
proven to be an extremely proficient
swimmer but you'd have to maintain your
grip across the entire pacific ocean
while it journeys to china in other
words it's technically possible but we
here at scp explained would rather pay
for the round-trip flight to each their
own though but that's enough theories
for now let's move on to the main event
hypotheticals you pose some great
possible scenarios involving scp-096
so we're going to see if we can find the
answers what would happen if someone
looked at a picture of it while in or
before entering another scp's pocket
dimension or mirror dimension there
aren't any canon examples to prove
either way but if there's any kind of
consistent entry point into this
dimension it's likely that 096 would
find a way to follow you in if not it's
very possible that it may just wait for
you to eventually return before bringing
the metaphorical hammer down on you so
technically if you were pulled into the
old man's pocket dimension and he closed
the portal you'd be safe from 096 but
then you've got a whole other problem to
deal with what happens if a person sees
his face then gets their memory of the
creature wiped considering how good the
foundation seems to be at wiping
people's memories and their access to
amnestics if this worked they probably
would have made it standard procedure by
now so it's unlikely what happens if a
person looked at it and that person then
went on a plane or just staying in the
air or space what would it do 096 has
shown the ability to jump up and destroy
low-flying aircraft but otherwise it's
likely that the creature would probably
run to a point directly below you and
remain there until you touch back down
since you'll need food and water at some
point and aircrafts need fuel you'd
probably just be prolonging the
inevitable what if the young girl was
around it so it tried to attack her but
died trying this is another interesting
possibility
scp-053 is a girl capable of causing
homicidal urges but causes fatal heart
attacks in those who attack her while we
can't know for sure how a meeting
between 096 and 0.53 would go we can use
her encounter with 682 as a potential
template aggressive scps like the hard
to kill reptile perhaps having an innate
knowledge of the danger that comes from
attacking zero five three tend to become
strangely docile around her it's
possible that 096 would do the same
would we be able to control scp-096 with
the help of scp-035
the possessive mask aka scp-035
is undeniably a lot more intelligent
than 096 and has even been shown to
respond to reason on occasion it's also
been able to control almost every other
entity it's been placed on the problem
is if the mask was placed on 096 and it
was somehow effective the result may be
even more dangerous than 096 an
intelligent monster with an
indestructible and highly dangerous body
there's no telling whether 0-3-5 would
slowly break down 0-9-6 into sludge the
way it does to humans in which case we
would be left with an immortal
096035 combo so maybe it's best that we
never find out if someone were to be in
the infinite ikea and looked at a
picture of its face could it finally be
contained and if someone else looked at
a picture of it outside of the infinite
ikea could it escape and kill them if so
how long would it take it this is a
great question and while the infinite
ikea is a terrifying maze
scp-096 has an advantage here that we
don't not only can it rip through
anything in the way with its super
strength it has an innate sense of where
its victim is therefore regardless of
whether you're inside or out
scp-096 will still come straight to you
to exact your horrible fate but at least
you can enjoy the meatballs while you
wait right and finally what would happen
if 096 were led into a room full of
mirrors and allowed or made to look at
its own face would it smash the mirrors
or try to rip itself to pieces this is
still a hotly debated issue to this day
which thanks to the no cannon nature of
the scp foundation does not have a
definitive answer some theorized that
this would at least be an effective
deterrent against scp-096
while others suggest that it wouldn't be
effective because many believe that 096
is actually blind and thus cannot see
its own face it can only sense when
other people see it again we don't quite
know for sure but it's likely to remain
one of the most contentious issues
around the shy guy for a long time to
come
what does a monster look like to you
what figures slither and claw their way
into your nightmares chasing you down
endless halls and stalking you through
the dark until you wake up screaming
maybe you imagine something tall and
lean bony arms reaching for you from
atop impossibly long slender legs its
featureless face showing no mercy maybe
you think of a man in a striped sweater
with knives for fingers or a serial
killer in a hockey mask wielding a
machete maybe it's something more
inhuman a cosmic horror of tentacles and
eyes that can see into your very soul
you probably don't think of something
with no arms no legs no body at all just
a face what's so scary about that a face
can't run after you can't grab you by
the ankles and pull you under the bed a
face can only
look it may be unsettling to behold it
might send a chill down your spine but
the worse it can do is make you a little
uncomfortable and if you can't stand it
any longer you could always just close
your eyes or walk away and be done with
it right if that's what you think if you
don't believe in monsters that can hurt
you without lifting a finger then you're
the type to fall victim to a very
special
very intelligent
mask in the hollowed halls of the scp
foundation there is a containment cell
outfitted with a hermetically sealed
glass case
surrounded by steel iron and lead there
are guards posted outside along with a
trained psychologist if you are ever
brave and foolish enough to enter that
room you'll see a simple white porcelain
comedy mask with a peculiar black
substance leaking from its eyes and
mouth whatever this slime touches
surfaces begin to corrode to rot away
into puddles of black liquid you might
notice the same liquid trickling slowly
down the walls of the room corrupting
everything in its path as unsettling of
a sight as it is if you approach the
mask to take a closer look you will find
yourself overcome by an intense nearly
irresistible urge to pick it up and put
it on to wear it to let it consume you
from the inside out and puppet your body
while your brain simply turns off
like an extinguished flame you'll simply
be gone
then who knows what the mask will do
it won't be your concern anymore that's
for sure but thankfully you haven't gone
into the room with the porcelain mask
you haven't let it cast its spell on you
not yet at least it's waiting for you
there in the room with black slime
oozing down its walls and it will wait
patiently for as long as it needs to
after all what's a mask without a face
to wear it
scp-035 better known as the possessive
mask sat in its containment cell
immobile as always it didn't really have
much of a choice in the matter the
foundation had chosen selfishly to
revoke its host privileges once upon a
time they offered it bodies to choose
from mannequins dummies and wooden dolls
that could adorn and pilot they didn't
last as long as an organic living host
of course but it was something it was a
taste of freedom this dreadful news
situation was almost enough to make the
mask want to change its surroundings
this dreadful new situation was almost
enough to make the mask want to change
its expression from comedy to tragedy
but it was determined to still find
something to laugh about even without a
body trapped in this infernal box there
had been some delicious opportunities
for entertainment human minds were
fragile things the mask had learned this
over the infinite years of its life if
one could call it a life apply the right
kind of pressure to the right weak
points whisper an enticing word or two
find the right emotional wound to
sprinkle a pinch of salt into and humans
would buckle completely in almost no
time at all it had tried all sorts of
methods since being confined to this
boring little box sometimes it would
charm someone pour honeyed flattery into
their heads until the person felt like
the mask was a dear friend a confidant
once suitable trust had been built up
the mask could persuade the person to
bring it a host or perhaps even offer up
themselves in sacrifice if flattery
didn't work there were other potent
approaches to take for a being without
ears the mask was a good listener it
picked up on things that no human ever
could the darkest secrets buried in a
person's mind if it caught wind of
something especially juicy and ruinous
it could leverage that threatened to
expose an affair a crime or perhaps
something even worse
something
unspeakable
if praise failed and so did blackmail
there was always good old supernatural
intimidation all the mask needed was for
someone to be left alone with it for a
long enough period of time
then its invisible tendrils could snake
out into their defenseless mind weaving
and poking around leaving a lingering
sense of cold dread of incomprehensible
whispers in long dead tongues
what a delight containment had been in
the early days when the foundation had
not yet figured out the mask's true
capabilities when they would leave
security personnel with weak wills and
minimal training standing guard in the
mask's field of influence for hours at a
time as the entity played with their
thoughts and chipped away at their free
will
thanks to the helpers it had been able
to mold out of those hapless victims
they had been there to break open its
case and carry it to freedom but every
time the other guards thwarted the
attempts shooting its helpers and
rendering them utterly useless then the
foundation increased its security
something about the unacceptably high
homicide rates among staff assigned to
scp-035
how utterly boring how truly
pathetic
still the mask had found ways to occupy
itself even without any more playthings
it had grown stronger with its boredom
stretching its influence beyond organic
beings and into the very room itself its
evil enriching and deepening like a fine
wine in the depths of a cold cellar over
the months the walls of
scp-035's containment cell had begun to
secrete the same black slimy substance
that would pour from the mask's eyes and
mouth the liquid dripped down the walls
in deliberate formations patterns that
became increasingly easy to recognize
phrases in italian latin ancient greek
all detailing ritual sacrifices and
mutilations the mask took time to
describe the sacrificial victims in
great detail borrowing identifying
traits from various staff members that
it knew would read the translations the
walls were slick with blood and
harrowing imagery and the glass case
around the mask was growing more and
more fragile by the day
anyone within 10 meters of the mask
could feel this strength too they would
leave the area complaining of
unintelligible whispers of loud cruel
laughter and a lingering sense of nearly
insurmountable despair it was as if they
knew on some level that no one was truly
safe eventually the mask would find a
way to come for them all the glass was
weakening and soon the mere thought of
escape would make it shatter into pieces
then perhaps the mass could finally get
its deepest desire
revenge
it wanted nothing more than to try to
make the foundation pay for imprisoning
it for taking away its host privileges
for trying harder and harder to contain
the kind of power that should have had
them falling to their knees in worship
the mask seethed with hatred day in and
day out it had seen the crumbling of the
roman empire the beheading of kings the
decimation of armies it was not going to
be captured by a bunch of rats in lab
coats without dire consequences
befalling them
maybe it couldn't move from its prison
cell at the moment but it also knew that
it was surrounded on all sides by
dangerous beasts capable of reducing the
sight and all who had dared to oppose
the mask to a pile of smoldering rubble
if it could only find its way onto one
of their faces it would show them all
just what it was capable of as the
piercing sound of an alarm echoed down
the hall the sound of screams and chaos
following shortly after the mask's
frowning face curved into a broad
menacing
smile
what was it that had escaped the lizard
perhaps the giant grinning man whatever
it was it seemed that the action was
heading right towards zero three five's
containment cell perhaps today was the
day
finally
the scp foundation
would fall outside the masked cell
security officer harper was running for
dear life though his more rational mind
knew he was living on seconds not even
minutes of borrowed time his animal
brain kept his legs pumping desperately
trying to avoid the screaming howling
predator hot on his heels harper looked
over his shoulder and screamed as a long
white arm reached for him
scp-096 the shy guy its toothline jaw
hanging low and foaming with spittle
that face that terrible terrible face an
absolute death sentence to all who saw
it he'd seen what he thought was a crack
in the otherwise perfect seal of 096's
containment chamber but it could have
just as easily been a trick of the light
not even thinking he stepped forward and
looked at the vulnerability in the
chamber all it took was one misplaced
ray of light and he made out the vague
shape of a face in the darkness
that's when the weeping started harper
knew in that moment his life was over
the correct thing to do would have been
to order everyone else in the room to
close their eyes while he stood there
and accepted his fate minimizing the
risk of spreading the damage further but
humans rarely have perfect reasoning
even less so when facing mortality back
in the present the shy guy made a
perfect lunge grabbing harper in its
iron clutches and barreling through the
adjoining wall the nearby guards
scattered terrified keeping their eyes
on the floor they might get a slap on
the wrist for temporarily abandoning
their posts but they weren't going to
die guarding some stupid evil mask
speaking of the possessive mask was
surprised to feel two new presences
enter its chamber through the now
destroyed wall these two presences soon
became just one as
scp-096 quickly and totally annihilated
security officer harper leaving nothing
left the mask couldn't see per se seeing
as it had no actual sensory organs but
it felt around this new guest with its
many psychic tendrils taking in this
strange totality the creature was
powerful no doubt about that and it
elicited fear from those fools at the
scp foundation but the mask noticed its
brain waves were extraordinarily muted
humans to the mask's vest and malicious
consciousness weren't the sharpest
knives in the drawer but compared to
this thing's mind they were a pile of
tempered katanas it barely thought at
all the mask would have to dig deeper to
find anything it could use
meanwhile scp-096
finally began to calm down the one who
had seen it had been annihilated
bubbling rage was slowly siphoned out
and replaced by the standard low but
constant hum of anxiety and despair it
would wait until its head was bagged and
it was dragged back to the dark same old
same old all the way to the end of time
that's when it felt something else it
started as a faint buzz an
unintelligible whisper and it was almost
like a door opened in the back of its
head something stepped in and took a
seat
you hear me stranger
look
i want to speak to you
something about the voice frightened and
comforted as cp09 at the same time it
spoke with a greater degree of sympathy
than the creature had heard in a long
time and yet something about the way it
spoke implied evil in its intent
if you could cover that face of yours
i can help you
it will be so simple
all you need to do
096 felt more of these strange thoughts
filling up the emptiness in its head
replacing the few little thoughts the
creature itself had it felt itself
lifting its hands from the ground
lifting them and reaching towards
something a glass box the glass
shattered and those long white fingers
reached for something within a mask just
like the voice had said a mask to stop
people from looking
at its face
yes
yes
the
[Music]
scp-096 lifted the mask to its face
feeling black liquid that burned its
skin dripping from the porcelain and put
it on and in that moment everything
changed the shy guy's body began to
seize up rattling as the mask unleashed
a web of psychic tendrils through its
body mapping out across every inch like
a new nervous system taking control the
possessive mask had never experienced a
host like this before that incredible
perfect mix of physical durability and a
mind so insubstantial that it was easy
to sublimate oh this
was going to be fun
for the first time the shy guy now under
the full control of the possessive mask
stood at full height on its hind legs
its spine and shoulders clicking into
place for its new stance the mask
cracked its neck getting used to the new
dimensions of its physicality its
indestructible bones its long grasping
limbs its skin
burning and fizzling with the gooey
black secretions but growing back just
as quickly the foundation had every
reason to fear it now
a group of security personnel had
gathered in the ragged hole where the
chamber's north wall used to be some
were wielding white firearms the guard
at the front was carrying an opaque
black bag the mask laughed with its new
body and turned to the crowd the second
they saw it on 096's body their faces
fell for a moment their bodies went
slack with terror this situation was
unprecedented what course of action
could they possibly take at a time like
this it looked at the bag held by the
leader of the security force and
projected a single thought into his mind
before any of the guards even had a
chance to open fire the mask lunged
forwards using the long terrible arms of
the shy guy to tear through the guards
they were dead in seconds their bodies
strewn about the hallway the mask's
porcelain was twisted into a wide
sadistic grin it could tell that it was
about to have some real fun around here
and once it slaughtered everyone here it
could finally stretch its legs out in
the open again true freedom to spread
misery fear and pain everywhere it went
there were just a few hundred members of
foundation personnel that needed to turn
into corpses first more containment
breech alarms sounded around the site as
the mask began its rampage running
through the hallways and tearing apart
any unfortunate foundation personnel it
could get 096's hands on
guards researchers administrative staff
and even one extremely unlucky janitor
in hallway c6 it was having the time of
its long and terrible life and much to
its glee it seemed that this new host's
body was still holding up it was perfect
symbiosis a twisted brilliant mind and a
body that could forever support it there
would be no stopping it a conclusion
that the hapless guards posted around
the site soon realized on their own
terms 096 was indestructible but it was
dumb as a brick and had an easily
exploitable weakness get the bag on its
head and your home free this new
composite creature was a different story
it could think tactically avoiding
head-on confrontations in favor of sneak
attacks and the monster had as much
psychic combat potential as physical
guards roving the building in teams
heavily armed with anti-mimetic
protective gear still reported feeling
immense feelings of psychological dread
over calms that was the greatest sign
that the mask would come bursting
through the wall moments later and tear
them to shreds the site director put out
an urgent call for all nearby mobile
task forces to intercept and help them
take care of the unfortunate situation
thankfully a detachment of mtf 8-10 also
known as see no evil was operating on a
case in close proximity given their
specialization in anomalies with a
memetic visual property many on the team
had dealt with 096 breaches before that
at least gave them experience in half
this situation and one operative among
them sergeant henrique ramirez would be
the one to bring this nightmare to an
end but it would cost him his life in
the process the mask was still using its
new indestructible body to wreak havoc
on the containment site once it had
taken out the primary contingents of
guards it was free to have its fun with
the rest stalking defenseless
researchers through the halls making
sure to induce maximum terror before
finally striking the killing blow every
single one of them died with a head full
of demonic whispers it told them of the
mask's eternal dominion now it had found
the perfect host nothing on earth would
stop it humans would be mere ants under
its feet eta 10 touched down and entered
the building ramirez was point man
leading the others into the bowels of
the blood-drenched containment site
they've been briefed on what they were
heading in for 096 and 035 had reached
symbiosis and were displaying
unprecedented anomalous effects enter
with extreme caution they're beyond
dangerous even more so together than
alone ideally ramirez would have wanted
to go in with a comprehensive plan but
lives were on the line here they needed
to leap off the cliff and build their
wings on the way down it was only when
they finally encountered the monster
that they realized just how outmatched
they were despite their best efforts the
combined speed intelligence and ferocity
of the mask's new form allowed it to
make short work of 8-10 only ramirez was
left heavily injured
even if a miracle happened he knew he
wasn't getting out of here alive the
mask grabbed him with one of 096's claws
and lifted him up it would take its time
with this one make him suffer watch him
squirm destroy his mind ramirez felt the
mask's psychic tendrils penetrate the
membrane of his mind those whispers
those terrible whispers reciting all his
worst fears with terrible glee his gun
was out of ammo his knife was broken all
he had left on him was a pocket mirror
and that was his eureka moment it was a
long shot but it was also his only shot
he reached out and grabbed the bottom of
the mask pulling for dear life his other
hand shot into his pocket and grabbed
the mirror opening its lid with a deft
flick of his thumb it was too fast for
the mask to even register what was going
on ramirez forced his eyes shut and
lifted up the mirror the mask saw its
own reflection in the glass as the
bottom of its face came loose revealing
the reflection of the face underneath
the mask squeezed killing ramirez but it
was already too late it had finally seen
the face of its host and that would cost
it dearly the mask felt a sudden and
tremendous pushback to its psychic
forces a blind despair and then rage
that choked out everything
scp-096 began to sob and howl somehow
the mask was no longer in control
despite its psychic protests the 096
reached up and tore the terrible mask
from its face tossing it against the
wall with such force that it was
embedded in the brickwork its last
thoughts as other mobile task force
operators descended on the area to bag
096 and return it to its containment
chamber were
what the hell just happened and the next
thought that crossed the mind of the
site director was request site transfer
for zero three five as soon as possible
don't want a repeat of this incident
anytime soon imagine knowing that
there's a monster right under your nose
imagine knowing that this monster is
capable of killing any human being on
earth and all because they simply saw a
photograph of its face when this monster
is on the warpath literally nothing can
stop it no weapon that human beings have
invented is capable of even slowing it
down
imagine knowing in the age of mass media
of clicks and shares of 24-hour news
smartphones and limitless social media
connecting billions across the globe
that one stray picture of this monster
leaked in the wrong place could cause
the end of the world as we know it and
this fateful terrifying day could come
at any time congratulations
you now know how it feels to be dr dan
the hot-headed lead scp foundation
researcher on the scp-096
case the anomaly itself requires no real
introduction the infamous mass murdering
shy guy has haunted the nightmares of
foundation experts for years but nobody
is more haunted by this thing than dr
dan himself for over a decade now he has
firmly believed that there's one
solution to the 096 problem termination
with extreme prejudice in his eyes to
think that 096 is ever truly contained
is an illusion they could never be sure
of how many pictures of it are out there
floating around just waiting to be seen
like a time bomb waiting to go off the
resources spent containing it and
cleaning up after its rampages he would
often argue would be better spent
instead figuring out how to finally kill
it but seeing as we're talking about the
scp foundation here not the global
occult coalition the o5 council didn't
see it quite the same way they
constantly overturned dr dan's
termination requests leaving the
paranoid researcher more furious with
each rejection he tried to warn them
again and again
and again don't you see it's like a
stick of dynamite and the fuse is
already lit if you don't let me put it
out before it's too late there won't
even be anyone left to pick up the
pieces but as please fell on deaf ears
until of course incident 096-a
a dark and bloody day still looked back
on with shame and horror by even the
most hardened members of foundation
staff it was the day that
scp-096 gave everyone a taste of the
mass carnage it was truly capable of dr
dan wasn't even there when containment
was first breached he was off on an
expedition in the snowy mountains where
096 was first found trying to discover
clues to its true origin dr dan's second
in command dr alexi was also lucky
enough to be outside of the containment
area when the shy guy escaped according
to interviews he gave at debriefing
tribunals he was in the break room
treating himself to a warm cup of joe
all the other personnel assigned to
096's containment and research were near
its containment chamber a giant cube
made of reinforced metal observing a
live feed of data being collected from
the cube's interior as usual sensors
indicated that 096 was pacing within for
obvious reasons the foundation doesn't
maintain any kind of live visual
surveillance on 096
it wouldn't be worth the risk but what
seemed like in otherwise quiet days
suddenly took a turn for the insane the
monitors began displaying terrifying
data indicating an imminent containment
breach as the whales of the creature
within the cube echoed out through its
metal walls some tried to run others did
all they could to engage emergency
procedures while guards armed with heavy
weaponry rushed into the room they all
knew in their hearts that it wouldn't
save them but what else could they do a
huge dent bulged out from the side of
the cube then another before the metal
was torn open like tissue paper as the
furious hands of the shy guy began
clawing their way through it secondary
layers of protection were deployed but
they didn't help 096 just kept ripping
through all the barriers as everyone in
attendance knew once it was in its rage
state nothing could stop it literally
nothing the guards attempted to fire on
the anomaly but their bullets did no
good as the creature burst free most of
the people in the room had at least
momentary visual contact with its face
and response code lima was declared and
the entire chamber was flooded with a
fast-acting nerve gas killing everyone
everyone except for 096 itself of course
within 2 minutes 096 had broken free of
the entire containment site and began
running through the desert at breakneck
speeds towards its distant target the
foundation needed to act fast and find a
way to stop it before it hit a
population center where the death toll
would skyrocket team echo romeo were
dispatched to pursue the creature in a
heavily armed attack helicopter while
mtf tau-1 a task force specializing in
scp-096 containment and recovery forged
ahead to identify the anomaly's target
designated
096-1 and to move any other civilians
out of harm's way dr dan was alerted of
the disastrous situation and offered
guidance to both teams from afar echo
romeo's chopper pursued 096 barely able
to keep up dr dan recommended attempting
to at least slow the creature down with
heavy arms fire even though he knew
actually stopping it would be impossible
a member of the team used a modified
xm500 anti-material rifle to fire
several rounds at the creature but even
the shot that passed directly through
its head appeared to have no effect on
it but at least they had a lock on its
direction now 096 always travels in a
straight line directly towards its
target smashing through any obstacles in
its way this means its intended
direction is relatively easy to track
and people in the path of its trajectory
are even easier to save but it's a high
pressure job reserve for mtf tau one tau
one passed over echo romeo and zero nine
six in the series of eight v-22 ospreys
hoping beyond hope that they could
outrun the creature since there were
several different towns in its direct
path but thanks once again to the one
and only dr dan echo romeo and tao 1 had
a secret weapon that neither team had
ever possessed before scramble scramble
was an advanced computer program created
by dr dan with the help of dr alexi
which was coded into microprocessors for
modification into camera feeds and
viewing goggles the program had been fed
intricate data concerning every single
detail of 096's face and as the name
suggests when encountering that visual
data in real life it scrambles it beyond
recognition in theory it would make it
far safer for operatives to be around
scp-096 without activating its rage
state in theory it wasn't long before
disaster struck
096 had made its way onto i-40 and had
begun attacking vehicles it encountered
killing the people inside by this point
it had already outrun the echo romeo
chopper rendering them essentially
useless tau-1 just had to forge ahead
along 096's trajectory and try to get as
many people out of the danger zone as
possible until 096-1 was located and
destroyed by the anomaly years of
training for an awful day like this had
paid off as the first three towns along
096's path were successfully evacuated
the shy guy just ran right through all
of them and no lives were lost the same
however could not be said for town
number four as was standard procedure
tau one had everyone in the town
gathered up and blindfolded the entire
team in attendance had modified night
vision goggles with scramble
microprocessors so in theory they were
better off than most from 096 if things
went south the tau-1 members tried in
vain to keep everybody in line they were
threatening to shoot anyone who dared to
remove their blindfold when 096 finally
appeared it tripped during its approach
rolling and shattering through several
houses chaos erupted some people
instinctively removed their blindfolds
to see what was going on and panic
members of taowan began firing into the
crowd the screams of the civilians and
the bursts of gunfire were all drowned
out by the horrific wailing of 096
itself as it tore through everyone and
everything to kill the unfortunate souls
who had seen its face and given how many
had removed their blindfolds during the
initial pandemonium
scp-096 had a huge number of the
townspeople on its list 096 located and
grabbed the original 096-1
the person that had first glimpsed its
face and caused all of this but in the
grand scheme of things he was just one
more body on the pile that day
though of course we mean this in a
purely metaphorical sense
096 never leaves entire bodies the
foundation operatives in attendance were
able to figure out what had caused all
this madness and death
096-1 had been an amateur mountaineer
and spent his vacations hiking around
any mountain ranges he could gain access
to including the mountain range that 096
had been inhabiting prior to its initial
capture and containment but he hadn't
actually seen 096 on that fateful trip
which had been taken over a decade ago
but in a photograph taken that day of
himself standing on a picturesque
mountainside 096 made a cameo it took up
all of four pixels a tiny off-white dot
against the snow on the back right side
of the photograph this photograph with
all the deadly potency of an atom bomb
had been sitting there for years
waiting when the mountaineer was looking
through old photos that morning and his
eyes passed over those few blurry pixels
he didn't have any idea that he had just
laid his eyes on one of the most
dangerous anomalies the world has ever
seen but you don't have to know
only096 does as tao 1 led by their
commander major jack wilford tried to
retake control of the situation things
got even worse it turned out dr dan's
scramble technology the one thing that
was supposed to have given them an edge
in this situation didn't actually work
as soon as goggle-wearing members of the
team laid eyes on 096 it entered its
rage state and started massacring them
it tore many of the mobile task force
members to shreds including a number of
the operatives required for piloting the
eight ospreys it was a disaster of truly
epic proportions and the catastrophic
failure of dr dan's scramble technology
was a key factor the root of the
technology's failure was easy enough to
figure out dr dan's scramble
microprocessors worked fast but not fast
enough fractions of a second glimpses of
096's face managed to get through and
that was more than enough to set 096 off
echo romeo and mtf epsilon arrived
shortly afterwards to clean up the mess
it'd been a disaster of such magnitude
that even a cnn reporter arrived on the
scene and started filming before being
promptly shut down by epsilon it was a
member of echo romeo that finally
slipped the bag over a docile zero nine
six his head preparing it for
containment once again the creature now
content that it had eliminated all the
unfortunate souls who had seen its face
he'd found 096 sitting next to a minivan
that had its roof ripped off the young
family inside being the last to have
seen its face
and things were so awful in the
aftermath of the containment breach that
the o5 council changed their tune
finally granting dr dan permission to
terminate 096 by any means necessary
it's terrifying to think that all this
can unfold because of a couple of poorly
timed accidents but it's probably even
more terrifying to consider that it
wasn't an accident at all it seemed
awfully convenient that both dr dan and
dr alexi were far from danger when all
hell broke loose it was also convenient
that despite the failure of his
technology being a major reason why the
breach was as deadly as it was dr dan
had still come out of the situation with
everything he wanted the foundation also
found this strange and the more they
looked into it the more they found
details that didn't add up alibis began
to fall apart coincidences didn't seem
so coincidental and eventually a weak
link in the chain was identified dr
o'lexi under pressure from the
foundation alexi spilled everything dr
dan had essentially orchestrated the
entire containment breach and on top of
that he did everything he could to make
it as deadly as possible all with the
purpose of getting the o5 council to see
things his way and finally give him the
permission he needed to devote all the
scp-096 resources to its termination but
it came at a terrible price to dr dan
personally for his crimes against the
foundation and humanity he was permitted
to try and figure out a way to terminate
096 once and for all but as payment for
his crimes he himself would also be
terminated as soon as his task was
complete where the lies of all those
innocent people and dr dan himself worth
the price of finally being authorized to
terminate
scp-096 when asked why he did all of
this dr dan simply said it worked it was
only a matter of time until that
happened in a major population center
and its face spread over the world news
i can kill 096 but i've killed myself in
the process while we don't agree with
his methods there's something almost
admirable about a person so
single-mindedly devoted to their cause
as you walk down the halls of the scp
foundation site 19 speaking in the
various windows at the anomalies
contained there you might catch a
glimpse of a dark figure bent over a
table tinkering away like an artisan in
his workshop a vintage black apothecary
bag sits next to him open and if you
stop and watch for a while you'll see
him pull all manner of tools out of it
impossibly large tools things that
shouldn't fit in such a small bag a bone
saw an iv stand jars of fluorescent
liquids and needles the length of your
forearm you shouldn't be surprised this
is a place for impossible things after
all still it's a curious sight the
shadowy man working so diligently so
quietly focused singularly on his craft
whatever that might be
only one thing could distract him from
his efforts you he feels your gaze on
him and he looks up dark eyes glittering
from behind a beaked ceramic mask he
reminds you of an illustration you once
saw in a book about the black death the
gear the plague doctors wore while
treating patients on their deathbeds
hello
he greets you in a friendly heavily
accented voice his eyes crinkled beneath
the mask and if you could see his mouth
you know he'd be smiling how are you
today dear fellow are you feeling quite
well he takes a step toward the window
stretching out one gloved hand and you
suddenly realize that you can't see
where the mask ends and his skin begins
it's not a mask but a part of his face
this is no ordinary man do you require
help i can examine you he offers palm
press flat against the glass a chill
runs up your spine and you realize that
you should definitely not take him up on
his offer no matter how friendly he
seems how good his intentions may be you
wouldn't want to let the plague doctor
treat you he sat in his containment cell
fidgeting with his favorite scalpel he
dragged it over the surface of his work
table back and forth listening to the
sound it made they had tried to
confiscate his table his tools the
guards had quickly learned that he had
more of them in his bag they tried to
take away his bag from him but well that
didn't go over too well for anyone
involved so he was allowed to keep it to
fashion himself a makeshift laboratory
in his lonely little cell there was a
time where they had given him test
subjects fresh corpses from the morgue
for him to dissect and research there
was a time when the doctors here would
come to speak with him talking of
cryptobiology and the pestilence he had
dedicated himself to fighting those days
were long gone he had hidden away pieces
of the corpses tissue samples and jars
of formaldehyde he could pull out when
the monotony became too much for the
days of fresh materials of enlightened
discourse with other men and women of
science were over how he missed those
days the chance to work with others as
he once had what had he done wrong all
he did was treat the sick sure they
didn't always understand their illness
didn't want to receive their medicine
but that wasn't a choice for the patient
to make that should have been up to the
physician perhaps they didn't trust his
expertise didn't see how his work served
the greater good like those who watched
jonas salk invent the polio vaccine or
louis pasteur rid milk of bacteria they
were confused by the advanced scientific
practices and feared that which they did
not understand he could forgive them for
their ignorance he was magnanimous that
way if only they would let him out of
this infernal room he could prove his
work's worth to them he could cure them
all begin a new era of wellness and
peace worldwide he didn't exactly sleep
but when he rested on his little cot in
the corner of the room he dreamed of
that future of a world healed by his
touch a knock at the door stirred him
from his reverie someone someone was at
the door of his containment cell he
glanced at the little window and saw a
guard there with a tray of food he
greeted the man with an enthusiastic
wave sustenance he didn't require the
food for survival of course but it
helped his mind work more efficiently it
reminded him of a time before these
fluorescent lights and these same four
walls of crusty bread with fresh butter
by the banks of the sin the little slot
opened in the door and the tray was
shoved through there was bread just as
he hoped a small dish of butter pot of
jam and a cup of tea still seeming he
picked up the cup at first taking a deep
breath ah
an herbal blend with fresh lavender
lovely he couldn't see the guard through
the window anymore but he called out to
him just the same thank you for the
libations he still had his manners after
all even in confinement he wished he
could have gotten a better look at the
man seen the pallor of his complexion a
tremor in his hand he thought he had
spotted sweat beating on his forehead
could he be ill the case required
further examination to be certain he
sighed clutching the cup of tea tighter
in frustration why wouldn't they just
let him work why must they scream at the
sight of his efforts flee from his
instruments it didn't seem fair still
the pursuit of science rarely was a
glamorous one he had learned as much
over the centuries one day though
history would look back on him kindly of
this he could be certain he was just
settling in and beginning to spread
butter across the admittedly stale bread
when a horrible sound shook him to
attention he had heard the noise before
though he had never seen its source it
was an ear-splitting scream a whale of
pure agony like the sound of a wounded
wild animal he had heard many many
screams during his life from patients
and those who stood in the way of his
work but until he had been brought into
custody of the foundation he had never
heard a scream quite like this one it
was pure rage devastation and suffering
mixed together wet with tears and loud
enough to rip through human vocal folds
whatever was crying out it was no mere
man more screams answered it and these
were very much human these sounds were
more familiar to him shrieks of pain
fear of desperate but futile attempts to
escape then the meaty thud of bodies
falling to the floor of torn off limbs
hitting walls and windows a loud crash
and the sound of something large moving
quite quickly through the halls
scientific curiosity got the better of
the doctor and he found himself moving
back to his little window face pressed
to the glass so hard his beak nearly
cracked it he couldn't see much of
anything just guards running down the
hall weapons drawn he saw one of them
fire heard the gunshot ring out but what
was he firing at then he saw it a pale
blur darting past the door whatever it
was it didn't so much as flinch when the
bullet ricocheted off its skin a long
thin arm crashed against the door
knocking the doctor backwards into his
work table he steadied himself and
climbed back to his feet taking in the
damage done to the door it was crumpled
in on itself nearly ripped off the
hinges and whatever had plowed into it
was already gone from the sounds of
chaos in the distance it had disappeared
around the corner with the guards
following it he inspected the ruins of
the door to his containment cell it was
useless now hanging loose and open well
that was an invitation he was hardly
about to decline he grabbed his trusty
bag tossed his scalpel back inside and
set off to see what all the commotion
was it was easy enough to follow the
trail of blood stark and vivid red
against the white tile floor and the
sound of gunfire human screams and that
loud long painful whale he had heard
before he walked at a leisurely pace
taking his time until the sound suddenly
stopped he rounded the corner and found
a mound of bodies guards and scientists
beaten and bloodied almost beyond
recognition it was quiet here save for
one sound the sound of weeping there in
the corner huddled over with its face to
the wall was a pale thin figure its
shoulders heaving with the force of its
sobs this poor soul was clearly in great
distress it was a peculiar sight
hairless and white extended arms wrapped
around itself as it cried excuse me the
doctor cried out to the pitiful creature
are you alright
do you need assistance it didn't answer
it just continued to cry had something
so despondent been responsible for this
destruction the dozens of corpses the
smashed in walls the crumbled doors and
shattered windows it seemed impossible
sure it was large and looked strong but
he had never seen a monster cry before
this couldn't be a dangerous creature
not when it was so sad he would help it
but first he would attend to some of
these bodies he sat his bag on the
ground and pulled out several vials of
liquid a set of syringes and a variety
of other surgical tools he might need
now after such a long hiatus he could
resume his work in a meaningful way he
couldn't be certain how long he worked
reviving these poor souls and
reconstructing their bodies as the pale
creature wept in the corner the sobbing
faded into the background for a while
becoming a kind of white noise as he
removed a liver here placed it in a
chest cavity there poked and prodded
injected and extracted testing out new
methods alongside tried and true cures
one by one the milky eyes fluttered open
rigor mortise stiff joints creaked into
motion sallow faces looking at his with
the vacant gratitude he saw in so many
patients over the years he didn't need
to thank him with their words the work
was its own reward he expected more
guards to arrive to attempt to contain
the situation but none came even as the
alarm blared overhead as for the morose
creature he didn't seem to notice his
presence at all not even when he had
brought all of the intact corpses back
to life the patient shuffled around the
room aimlessly waiting for orders of
some kind the doctor tapped one on the
shoulder and handed the reborn man a
vial of thick black medicine give this
to the poor fellow in the corner please
it wasn't much but it should calm him
provide some relief from his suffering
the corpse nodded mouth hanging loose
and open an eyeball dangling unseen from
the socket he shuffled over to the
strange creature and held out the vial
to it it turned lifting its head and as
it locked eyes with the cured patient
something shifted in its face its mouth
opened wide impossibly wide and a treat
that same terrible sound as before tears
streamed from its colorless eyes its
arms shaking with unbridled rage as its
jaws locked around the patient's head
like a boa constrictor in one fluid
motion it swallowed the revived man
whole while the doctor watched in shock
he had been wrong this was not an
innocent creature caught in the wrong
place at the wrong time this creature
whatever it was was deeply sick he had
never seen such an advanced aggressive
case of the pestilence he'd heard rumors
of course but never encountered it
firsthand as a doctor he had sworn to do
no harm but in a drastic situation
drastic measures have to be taken it was
well known by himself and the doctors at
this foundation that he could cause any
and all biological functions in an
organism to cease with a single touch
and so he approached the creature arm
outstretched ready to administer that
necessary touch to protect the rest of
his patients as he approached the
creature turned to him its eyes wide and
blank an endless stream of tears pouring
from them spilling onto the floor it
shrieked again mouth stretching wide
enough to engulf his entire head and ran
toward him at a breakneck speed i am so
sorry you are not well the doctor said
simply as his hand pressed to the
creature's chest as soon as the tough
hide of the doctor's hand which the
uninformed might mistake for gloves made
contact with the unpigmented skin of the
beast its eyes closed its muscles went
slack and it collapsed to the ground
with a mighty thud the doctor paced
around the fallen creature taking in the
sight then something strange caught his
eye the creature's chest still rose and
fell was it his imagination he checked
its pulse and thought it was slow and
faint and though was slow and faint it
was very much present the creature was
still alive it had merely been rendered
unconscious by his touch rather than
completely deceased curious
very curious indeed he muttered perhaps
there were comorbidities present other
infections aside from the pestilence
which rendered the creature unnaturally
strong resilient to the usual courses of
treatment what would cause these
abilities this intense aggression it
seemed to be brought on whenever someone
looked at the entity's face if only he
studied psychology more the science of
the mind and its inner workings since he
had no experience with therapy nor was
he certain this creature could
communicate using language at all there
was only one way to find out more about
how this creature's brain worked he
would have to take it apart and see for
himself it was slow work getting the
massive creature back to the doctor's
containment cell it required the help of
his cured patients who grasped it by its
massive limbs and dragged the limp body
through the halls once back in a
familiar environment his work table
ready and waiting the doctor instructed
his assistants to place the new patient
on the table it was a bit small unable
to accommodate the creature's distended
limbs but if he attempted to use an
official foundation laboratory he risked
discovery and subsequent interruption so
it would have to suffice first he set up
an iv stand filled with a vivid green
liquid it was easy to find a vein the
creature's skin was nearly translucent
now that he could be certain the
creature would not wake during surgery
he could make the first incision scalpel
he held out a hand and his favorite
surgical blade was placed in it by one
of the helpful patients
thank you he slid the scalpel along the
hairline of the creature or where the
hairline would be if it weren't
completely bald once the scalp was
removed he set it aside for later when
it could be reattached bonsa please he
held out his hand again and again his
assistant gave him the proper tool this
however was when things got strange the
doctor had always been a deft hand at
cutting he'd once even received tutelage
from the great robert liston but no
matter how hard he tried to saw it never
left a scratch on the creature's
skeleton naturally this was somewhat
frustrating he wanted to study the
creature's brain tissue to get a sense
for what was going up there
neurologically and he couldn't do that
if it was impossible to saw off the
creature's cranial cap he blunted two of
his favorite saws while trying
thankfully there was still a solution to
access the beast's gray matter a little
trick he learned while studying the
funerary practices of the ancient
egyptians he produced a long curved hook
from his bag and inserted it up the
creature's nasal passage with some fine
maneuvering he eventually managed to
remove the brain it was such a terrible
shame that he needed to do it piece by
piece via the nasal passage but one
makes do all that was left was to sew
the skin of the creature's head back
into place it was mid-stitch when a
voice interrupted his careful work
nearly making him drop the needle hey
what are you doing he looked up to find
a guard aiming a gun at his face excuse
me i am in surgery at the moment please
do not interrupt he admonished the guard
but the man did not listen or lower his
weapon in fact he shouted something into
the radio code words the doctor didn't
recognize then he fired a bullet into
the skull of the patient standing at his
side how
dare you
the doctor cried readying himself to
confront the guard but it was too late
dozens of other guards were swarming the
room and neutralizing his assistance
some in hazmat suits grabbed his arms
and pulled him away from the creature on
the operating table no matter how hard
he fought or how loudly he protested
then something incredible happened
something wonderful the creature opened
its eyes and sat up it looked directly
at the guard closest to it and the two
saw one another's faces the guard tensed
preparing for the worst but nothing came
the creature simply stared placid and
quiet no screaming no tearing at flesh
no mouth opening wider and wider to
swallow the manhole i did the doctor
shouted overcome with elation i've cured
you now begins the rest of your happy
life you watched as the guards led the
shockingly calm creature away back to
its containment cell the doctor's door
was repaired and he was returned to his
state of captivity but he never forgot
the patient he helped that day and how
marvelous it felt to do such a good deed
meanwhile
scp-096's brain regrew within the hour
and caused another massive containment
breach murdering a variety of
researchers and guards but the staff
agreed not to tell scp-049 about any of
this better to just let him have this
one he really seemed like he needed a
win the scp foundation's hallowed halls
have been the site of many great and
puzzling mysteries among them being who
was the true creator of scp-173
the neck snapping sculpture what are the
secrets that dr alto clef is keeping
about his past who are the true seven
children of the scarlet king who was as
cp 106 the old man before he got all
nasty and of course what is the true
nature and origin of scp-096
the violent terrifying and incredibly
withdrawn shy guy it's a question so
great that we knew even our experts here
at scp explained couldn't take on the
mission alone that's why we pooled the
resources of you the loyal viewers of
scp explained to find the answer we made
a community post asking for your
personal theories on how the shy guy
came to be and you didn't disappoint
sending in a calvicade of curious
conjecture that we just can't wait to
explore so let's hop right in and see
what all of you had to say here is puffy
shades theory he was a lost british
d-class named martin mcgregor on a risky
experiment in colombia regarding
scp-1290
a d-class prisoner was teleported to an
unknown mountainous location after a
malfunction in the device he stayed
there for 37 hours before dying of his
bullet wounds from being shot by foreign
soldiers wherever the d-class was
teleported to was a foreign country not
welcomed to outsiders as we know there
have been some scps that have escaped
the grasp of the foundation the
foundation has located them but never
been able to see or capture them
continuing with the story it is
speculated that one of these entities
that is still undiscovered had the power
of necromancy they brought the d-class
back to the mortal world but in an
immortal form to terrorize humanity
forever the entity brings humans back to
life as supernatural beings their powers
being determined by their former
personality the resurrected d-class was
always shy self-conscious of his
unattractive face as you can probably
guess this resulted in the birth of our
good old friend shy guy certainly a
fascinating direction to go with a basis
in recorded anomalous activity and much
like a few other anomalies originating
from d-class personnel such as
scp-2419 the laughing men and
scp-4973 the dead men walking it would
feel oddly satisfying to see another one
of the foundation's greatest mistakes
become one of the gravest threats here
is diamond star lemon's theory the shy
guy was andrew irvine one of the two
mountaineers that went missing who were
part of the british expedition that was
sent to reach the top of mount everest
in 1924.
while andrew and his friend george
mallory were heading for camp 5 they
encountered
scp-1529 at different intervals since
mallory's body was eventually found in
1999 this tells us that irvine also
encountered 1529 irvine constantly
rejected 1529's offers and eventually
developed a defense mechanism where he
gets aggressive and attacks scp-1529
in return 1529 prolonged his life by
years to make him suffer every single
minute his skin turned white due to
constant exposure to the sun and he took
all of his clothes off due to
hypothermia this is confirmed because
mallory's body was just as wide as her
vein and a letter he said to his family
says that andrew became very shy and
barely speaks and he eventually
disappears mallory then encounters 1529
and punches him in the face and then
malory falls unconscious leading to his
death meanwhile irvine loses his sanity
and has his body disfigured and his
hands developed claws for better
climbing this is another popular theory
which has its roots in pre-existing
anomalous knowledge the horrific
tortures by scp-1529 the mountain king
against andrew orvin is believed by many
to be the root of the shy guy's creation
of course we can't know for sure but
some compelling evidence undeniably
points in this intriguing direction here
is number one tryhard's theory i think
he was one of the subjects in the
russian sleep experiment that escaped
and ran into the siberian mountains
became aware of the monstrosity he had
become and became violently
self-conscious this is a strange and
creative theory wrapping 096 in with the
lore of the legendary russian sleep
experiment russia does have its fair
share of snowy mountain ranges and the
experiment did turn its unfortunate
subjects into horrifying monsters but
the nature of these monsters did differ
significantly from the shy guy showing
higher intelligence but far less
durability against physical trauma here
is avery spencer's theory i have
wondered if perhaps he was part of an
almost death love pass incident and was
the sole survivor being in such a
position he was forced to eat his
comrades he then took on almost wenigo
aspects but instead of the bloodthirsty
feelings most got he became so ashamed
of what he did he can no longer tolerate
someone looking at him this is another
incredibly interesting theory that has
its basis in both russian legend and
real life history there have been a
number of events in the snowy mountains
of russia much like the d'atlov pass
incident which have left high altitude
tragedies in their wake one of these
traumatizing its victims to the point of
them turning into an anomalous creature
like scp-096 definitely doesn't seem out
of the question here is kriyakol's
theory shy guy has no face his face does
not exist not in the sense that it's
just smooth skin the face is actually
nothing he is a body and mind directly
attached to a pattern screamer humans
expect humanoid-shaped creatures to have
a face thus when someone sees his face
the screamer takes over and destroys
that person so it can stop existing his
body has changed over the years to
facilitate eliminating people who see
the face more effectively this is why he
wants to disappear in the desire camera
finish being nothing so people stop
filling in his face a way it could have
happened is an incomplete encounter with
3930 the one who became the shy guy
leaned in and just his face ceased to
exist though he probably would have
already needed some anomalous traits to
survive that this is another extremely
original and interesting theory based in
pre-existing anomalies of course there's
no real way to prove that scp-096's face
isn't a pattern screamer given that to
look upon it is to court death so we may
just need to take your word on this one
here is lens attack's theory perhaps 096
is an alien from a planet or dimension
that's completely dark where being seen
is a death sentence because of the local
anomalous fauna he somehow wound up in
our universe perhaps 096 is cursed that
whoever sees him will eventually
transform into something much worse or
become a portal into a dark dimension
and he does us all a favor by
eliminating these people before that can
happen another two extremely interesting
theories both of which could potentially
hold water they seem consistent with the
fact that scp-096 takes no pleasure in
the killing of its victims it only seems
to be doing it out of the sense that it
feels compelled into action here is
chill me's theory he could be the
physical embodiment of the feeling of
body dysmorphia another very valid
theory given scp-019
general temperament and caustic
reactions to being perceived in any way
here is renan roman's theory what would
happen if dr bright looked at
scp-096's face i mean his host would
certainly be killed but what would
happen as soon as dr bright picks
another host would scp-096
instantaneously charge at the new host
and kill it as well hmm an interesting
theory and one that we've explored
ourselves on videos concerning dr bright
before it's another good reason that
this particular scenario should be
placed on the dr bright is not allowed
list though even though dr bright does
occasionally beg for death this is one
horrifying recursive fate that even jack
himself probably wouldn't enjoy here is
han guy's theory from what i heard there
are two theories one was that he was a
mountaineer that survived an encounter
with the king of the mountain and had to
adapt to the mountain to survive both
from him and the mountain itself or he's
actually one of the children of the
scarlet king while we've covered the
mountain king theory this scarlet king
theory is all new could scp-096 be a
child of the terrifying scarlet king
he's certainly destructive but perhaps
he lacks the true knowing malice the
sadism that make the big red armored
lunatic proud he certainly doesn't have
an abject hatred of a 682 here is claude
cat's theory i wouldn't be surprised if
he was a species and came to be that way
as it is perfectly hidden they blend in
with the snow and if anyone saw its face
to know it was there they couldn't
document it for obvious reasons this is
an interesting and terrifying concept a
whole species of shy guys this is
another good reason to ardently fight
against climate change if all the snow
melts there will be nowhere for them to
hide anymore here is dan wolf's theory
the idea of if a tree falls and no one
is around to hear it is his origin he is
the physical manifestation of all the
energy of all the things unseen the
sound of a falling tree the transparent
skin of fish in the abyssal zone
development on half-life 3
all these things exist but they do so
unseen
shy is physical manifestation of that
metaphysical energy he didn't exist
until he was seen thus he came to be
existing is painful to him so he kills
anyone who sees his face the thing we as
humans use to identify one another in a
hope to be unrecognized and unknown to
eventually no longer exist this is a
fascinating theory our one question is
how he could ever be seen if by
definition he is an avatar of the unseen
what would cause these lapses in
non-existence it raises an interesting
metaphysical quandary in and of itself
here is jonathan collier's theory the
shy guy is a creation of the plague
doctor who engineered him in the french
alps he began as a human but the
doctor's process mutated him into his
current form he designed him to destroy
the pestilence but he was infected by it
somewhere in the process this means that
whenever someone sees his face they
catch the pestilence his programming can
allow this so he is forced to destroy
whoever sees him the doctor's
programming was incomplete when he was
corrupted so he only hunts those that he
has infected with the pestilence not all
that the plague doctor deems infected
his indestructible form is a combination
of the plague doctor's tinkering and
treatments as well as the doctor
potentially incorporating dna from other
anomalous creatures such as 682 which
did visit france in lord blackwood's
tales the doctor likely kept the dna in
reserve for his ultimate device to
destroy the pestilence however it failed
and led him to releasing the shy guy to
roam the mountains traveling eventually
from the alps to the himalayas where he
was discovered the creature cries as it
kills its victims because of its human
beginnings and its apparent anxiety is
likely the lingering emotion it felt
before it was transformed leading to it
being repeated for the rest of its
existence we love the plague doctor here
at scp explained so we're always happy
to consider fun potential crossovers
featuring him with some of our other
favorite anomalies the one thing working
against this theory is that 096 is an
uncharacteristically effective creation
for the plague doctors standards most of
which are janky disfigured zombies
sorry049
here is devin linder's theory i always
felt like 096 was possessed by an evil
spirit that lives in the frost
essentially the original native story of
a wendigo it just all makes sense
deformities and strength lives in the
cold hunts and kills people i don't know
if there's anything about looking at a
wendigo in the original stories though
the algonquin myth of the wendigo
certainly does have some similarities to
scp-096
however it has a little more in common
with another anomaly scp-320
the wendigo skull which forces its
wearers into spontaneous acts of
violence and cannibalism though if ever
096 found itself wearing the wendigo
skull we'd all be in terrible trouble
here is epic kitty 101's theory not
really a theory it's just what i want it
to be i believe that 096's actions are
derived from trauma it could very well
be a species and might be a different
version like albino so whenever someone
looks at its face it feels as though
that person was so inconvenienced by its
looks it wants to kill them because he
thinks they hate him now he believes he
isn't good enough for anyone's standards
we can all relate to that feeling now
and then and the hysteric crying and
wailing of scp-096 undeniably suggests a
level of psychological trauma one thing
we know for sure it definitely inflicts
trauma on the rest of us here is lemon
demon dangerous theory hear me out when
daybreaks was actually a primitive event
and the shy guy was the result without
any people to go around for the next
several millennia the shy guy grew fond
of the lack of company ultimately
turning him into the person or monster
he is today this is a fascinating one
however there is some pre-existing
evidence such as the tale unexpected
light which we've covered in a video on
this channel that suggests scp-096
survived into the reign of scp-001 when
daybreaks though sadly according to that
tale he didn't survive beyond it here is
andrew colen's theory i have a theory he
was born with some deformities and super
strength and was mocked for it as he
grew older the deformities grew more
noticeable so maybe the years of trauma
and abuse or whatnot could have caused
him to self-isolate and attack violently
against anyone who sees him this
definitely reflects the internality that
many people believe as cp096 has a
frightened insecure creature spiting its
own creation and anyone unfortunate
enough to look upon it though we'll
never really know how exactly it got
there here is stripey socks 101's theory
he could have been one of the scp-1000
instances but born hairless and unable
to think so was abandoned by its parents
another good cross-anomaly connection
however 096 is significantly more
durable than any member of scp-1000 as
well as having far more freakish
proportions so it's unlikely to have any
real relation to this advanced species
of apes here is blue iblis's theory well
based on his height his reaction to his
face being seen and how quick he is
scp-096 is literally just an irl
enderman they're both tall they're both
able to move quickly and become
instantly pissed if you look at their
face or eyes this probably means 096 is
maybe from another dimension but it's
just a theory we might dismiss a
potential minecraft influence out of
hand or not for the existence of
scp-4335
also known as a welt in the crucible an
evil minecraft monster however this
monster was actually the one responsible
for the endermen in minecraft due to a
foundation inspired patch sadly
invalidating this theory here is james
bevin's theory my theory is that the shy
guy is a demon summoned by a cult that
dwelled in the mountains they hoped to
control him but were unaware that the
entity reacts violently whenever anyone
sees its face and all met a grisly death
scp-096 is undeniably rather demonic so
we couldn't argue with this theory on
that front it's also very likely that
any cult who unwittingly summons him
without the knowledge of his primary
anomalous effect would meet a truly
gruesome death at his claws and teeth so
you may be onto something here james
here is harrison o'leary's theory well
when he left the mushroom kingdom he
obviously lost his mask and clothes the
idea that the shy guy is literally well
a shy guy is certainly an intriguing one
though how 096's long gangly body could
fit in those tiny compact outfits is an
open question if only researcher mario
and researcher luigi would take some
time off of their extremely busy
schedules to help us out with that one
oh no
oh
not luigi time
here is roninsky's theory he was a very
handsome man who was experimented on and
now goes into violent fits of rage when
people look at his now disfigured face
is it just us or is the idea of a
strangely handsome scp-096 somehow even
more disturbing than the one we already
have just feels so unnatural
he's waiting for you in the dark he sits
cross-legged still as a placid lake and
patient as a praying monk six feet deep
in meditation he's been like this for so
long his body oil slicked with deadly
black grease skin ancient and haggard
eyes black and flat with the kind of
calm you'd only find in crawling insects
and great white sharks his lipless mouth
is stretched across his jawbone in an
ugly black rectus he may be an old man
but trust us he's got plenty of new
tricks he'd love to show you he sat in
the loneliest place in the world the
deep dark bowels of an scp foundation
containment site surrounded by a complex
confluence of containment measures
different shapes running liquids bright
lights the kind of steel so thick a
nuclear weapon would only leave it
scuffed all the things that had a
tendency to
confuse him because that's all they ever
did the old man laughed to himself very
quietly all the people out there are so
scared of him because of one immutable
fact he isn't trapped here he's just
resting by virtue of his unique
anomalous abilities to pass through
solids at will and resist any form of
physical damage they can dole out there
is no way to really contain him like all
the others all the scp foundation could
hope to do was make leaving inconvenient
enough for him to make his little
adventures on the outside less appealing
than just sitting around doing nothing
after all he had all the time in the
world when you always have a later
there's a lot less pressure to do
anything now
like all thinking creatures and please
be aware that scp-106
the wretched terrifying old man is very
much a thinking creature he was subject
to occasional boredom and when most
people are bored they might play a video
game watch a few youtube videos or
re-watch it's always sunny in
philadelphia for the fifth time but for
the old man killing boredom involved
well killing people but not just killing
people of course truth be told for him
killing was really the least
entertaining part of the whole affair
the screams the begging the desperate
pleas
warm tears on shaking cheeks convulsions
of pain cold sweats
fear so intense it gives way to
gibbering madness the dull sheen of dead
hope in their eyes when they realize
that their doom is inevitable and that
he their captor their torturer would
decide the exact moment they slipped
into the void of that that was what he
lived for if you could call what the old
man did living he cracked his neck and
licked his teeth was he salivating all
those thoughts about pain seemed to have
got him worked up he could feel the
distant thumping of his heart old black
blood pumping through the dusty
corridors of his vascular system
synapses booming and sparking with
excitement at the thought of plumbing
new depths of human misery like a
scholar of suffering a pioneer of pain
all those silly foundation drones with
the audacity to think they're in control
he'd teach them to scream again
meanwhile in the room for the old man's
containment chamber all hell was
breaking loose monitors on the monster's
vitals were all spiking heart and brain
activity peaked just as they always did
before the old man decided to get active
cameras in his containment chamber
showed him rising steadily to his feet
cracking his joints limbering up his
body started to produce that terrible
corrosive mucus at an accelerated rate
pooling around his feet and unleashing
squalls of noxious fumes as it melted
into the floor
years of foundation testing and they
still couldn't find any material that
could withstand that vile black slob as
the old man began strolling towards the
wall a containment specialist in the
control room grabbed a nearby phone and
sounded the alarm for the containment
breach they needed a mobile task force
and every guard on site mobilized to
tackle 106 before he got into the
facility proper and started causing
havoc they couldn't risk it escaping
either the infamous incident when the
old man escaped for a halloween massacre
still haunted the nightmares of many a
staff member he had to be stopped now
a small fighting force was quickly armed
and assembled along with armor and
several high-intensity portable lights
to hopefully slow the monster down in
time for them to grab a d-class and set
up the femur breaker by the time they
all reached the hallway they intended to
use as a choke point for the escape the
old man was already halfway through the
outer layer of defense phasing through
the wall with that same terrible manic
grin he always had when he was about to
inflict terrible violence for the sheer
fun of it the guards and task force
members trained their lights and weapons
on him all of them had seen terrible
things on the job the kind of things
that would saddle almost anyone with a
lifetime of trauma but almost nothing
compared to the horror of direct
engagement during a 106 containment
breach that terrible old coffin dodger
was hell on two legs when they
discovered to their horror that the
lights didn't seem to be slowing him
down as much as anticipated they fell
back on plan b that b standing for blast
the living hell out of him with
everything they had the personnel opened
fire pumping round after round into his
dark form while each gave a loud meaty
splatter the old man didn't even flinch
when he was close enough all those
months of lethargy gave way to sudden
deadly speed in many ways the old man
was like a crocodile a fierce and
intelligent ambush predator who
conserved his energy wisely he could
seem so deceptively languid that you
could easily mistake him for something
slow and harmless but when you got
within arm's reach the sudden quickness
and ferocity would take you off guard
and by then it's already too late within
30 seconds the old man was the only
thing left alive in that hallway all the
guards and task force operatives sent to
slow him down lay dead dripping with his
black mucus there was silence save for
the quiet fizzing of the mucus eating
into their clothes and skin the old man
sighed how boring he'd killed so many
people now it all started to seem a
little
samey how many screams could you hear
before they all just blended into a
single shrill wine you can get sick of
even your favorite meal if you eat it
too often but that didn't matter the old
man had a different order of business
today he happened to be inside an scp
foundation containment facility filled
with so many fascinating specimens of
non-human entities that the one they
called scp-106
simply couldn't wait to torture he'd
only met a small portion of the ones
they had contained here but given what a
fascinating experience his past attack
on his fellow anomalies was he couldn't
wait to meet some more meanwhile the
site's top brass did all they could to
try to mobilize a second response to the
rogue senior citizen from hell currently
strolling through their high security
containment facility could they get in
contact with other mobile task forces
deployed in the area maybe they could
get hammered down or samsara in on this
mess before anything got really out of
hand the old man seemed more intent on
something this time they suspected even
the femur breaker might not work in
luring him back until he claimed
whatever he deemed to be his prize maybe
they should contact the o5 council
security guards were tracking 106's
progress through the facility via their
vast networks of security cameras they
warned any research administration and
janitorial staff to clear out of his
path unless they felt like being
tortured to death he hadn't dragged
anyone into his pocket dimension yet so
whoever that privilege was reserved for
would probably be getting a particular
sticky experience they could only
speculate as to the silent beast's
intentions one guard noticed something
when cross-referencing 106's movements
with a map of the facility they were
able to triangulate where he was heading
straight for the containment chamber of
scp-096
the guard's lips curled into a slight
smile thinking if one of you freaks can
actually kill the other maybe something
positive will come out of this disaster
the old man was having a stroll down
memory lane the time prior when he broke
out of his cell and decided to hassle
his fellow inmates was certainly
eventful he wound up in the company of
some cantankerous reptile and a korean
fox woman an unlikely pair if ever there
was one after finding himself in a room
with them he decided they should have a
little more privacy and dragged them
back into his pocket dimension for
further fun of course with two at once
his attention had been a little split
they spent as much time tussling with
each other as resisting his attempts to
torment them they definitely put him
through his paces that day and he gave
far better than he got after so many
hours of brutal mutilation there was
barely any of the lizard left despite
its frustrating insistence on quickly
healing from so many of its wounds still
it was good exercise even if the results
had been a little less than satisfying
if he could get another anomaly alone
though he'd be able to take his time and
really savor the pain he caused oh that
sounded heavenly
soon he came upon an incredibly strange
containment chamber that quickly caught
his eye it looked like a huge metal cube
with no way in or out not even a seam
whatever was trapped in there the old
man thought it must be something that
even the fools at the scp foundation
really truly wanted nothing to do with
but even more so than the strange sight
it was the sound that drew the old man
in tempting him like a siren song it was
weeping a soft sobbing keen that
betrayed a bottomless well of misery
whatever was making that crying sound
had known true despair or whatever
passes for true despair before you've
had a close encounter with the old man
in his pocket dimension the old man
grinned and thought oh sonny i'll give
you something to really cry about
he stepped forward and phased his way
into the metal cube the creature was in
the corner in contrast to that stupid
lizard this monster was pleasingly
humanoid with presumably all the
familiar pain points
splendid the only real difference was
color and proportion it was far longer
and ganglier than the average human with
grayish skin and no hair anywhere on its
body still it was something the old man
could work with the creature didn't even
seem to register his presence he just
sat crumpled in the corner weeping still
grinning his lunatic grin the old man
approached and rested a moist hand on
the creature's shoulder its pale skin
began to fizzle from the intruder's
corrosive touch a pool of vile sludge
began spreading out beneath his feet
until the creature was encompassed too
little by little they sank into the old
man's favorite place out of the world
the pocket dimension his own personal
eternal infinite dungeon where the only
laws are pain and terror for all but the
old man himself little did he know
this time the scores may be a little
more even on that front they both stood
in that terrifying labyrinth of hallways
and chambers where the old man had made
countless lives infinitely worse than
any terrible afterlife that could follow
them and still this creature didn't seem
to change its reaction he was almost
irritated by it and what's more this
whole time the creature hadn't even
turned to look at him he'd have to fix
that too
the old man with his shocking strength
gripped the monster's shoulder and
whipped him around staring into his face
bearing his black eyes and manic's smile
but he couldn't help find what looked
back at him
disconcerting its eyes were blank and
white its face stretched and warped into
a permanent grimace like munch's old
painting the scream and the second the
old man laid eyes on it that's exactly
what it did its gaping mouth let out the
most terrible whale the old man had ever
heard in all his years of torturing it
was a scream of unknowable sadness and
fear but somehow the old man sensed that
this creature didn't fear him it feared
itself feared what it was about to do
what the hell had he dragged down here
with him without warning the terrible
whales soon gave way to sudden and
ferocious aggression just like the old
man had dealt out to a group of
foundation guards and mobile task force
agents earlier that same night it was
only out of a mix of pure luck and his
own finely tuned animal instinct that
the old man was able to dodge the first
strike from the creature's long lith
forelimb he couldn't believe it they
were in his special place and this
victim of his had the audacity to fight
back well he'd soon put this monster in
its place as the monster continued
roaring and swiping for him the old man
simply walked backwards into a nearby
wall disappearing into a black stain of
course the monster better known to the
foundation as
scp-096 or the shy guy simply crashed
through the wall to give chase but on
the other side just another wall he
disappeared how typically when something
sees the face of the shy guy he
immediately has a kind of intuitive
connection to them he can sense their
presence it's burned into his mind a
homing beacon an unstoppable imperative
he knows exactly where they are and how
to get them but nothing about this
situation was typical the shy guy felt
all the murderous rage he normally did
but the rest was just static where was
the life he needed to abolish hiding
suddenly the old man emerged behind him
and forced his hand into the shy guy's
back his fist melted straight through
flesh and skin causing the creature to
let out another terrible whale but as
could be expected they didn't leave a
scratch on the shy guy's indestructible
skeleton the shy guy pulled a 180 and
swung for the old man again but he was
already gone here in the pocket
dimension the old man had the ultimate
home turf advantage here space and time
were his playthings in the infinite
twisting labyrinthian walls of the
pocket dimension the old man wasn't just
the devil he was god too
but it would take far more than some
cheap tricks and bodily harm to dissuade
the shy guy from his sole purpose in
life he began running through the old
man's personal maze like a crazed lab
rat tearing through wall after wall
forever searching for the monster that
trapped it here he would see the smiling
face of that rotten old man every so
often the flash of black eyes and dirty
teeth and shadows but every time it
tried to strike the shadows there would
be nothing there and every time he got a
chance the old man would emerge from the
shadows behind the shy guy to strike
back clawing into his flesh and
vanishing again before the trapped beast
could retaliate the nasty old sadist was
now starting to have some fun it was a
reflex test a classic game of
high-stakes whack-a-mole and every time
the creature failed to strike him its
distress only seemed to grow this was
perfectly fine for the old man after all
he enjoyed a little mental torment as
much as he loved physical torture and a
human would have died or given in to
despair long before now this monster's
wonderful mix of resilience and pain
made it a great chew toy the old man
kept up this routine baiting and
striking until something unanticipated
happened he appeared waited for the
swing disappeared as it approached then
reappeared behind the shy guy to deliver
another painful strike this time however
it seemed his victim had anticipated his
pattern before he could hit the creature
the shy guy turned quicker than anything
the old man had ever seen and hit him
with such force he flew through several
walls in his own maze shattering them as
he went he hit the ground stunned by the
fact that the shy guy had actually
landed a hit but he wasn't done the
shrieking monster came bounding after
him before the old man could stand it
struck him again
and again and again pounding his vile
body into the ground which cracked and
crumbled the old man sneered and sank
into a puddle of his mucus on the ground
the old man was gone again
scp-096
screamed in a mix of rage despair and
frustration so consumed with its hunt
that it didn't notice the pool of
corrosive mucus was slowly growing it
began to rise bubbling and hissing at
scp-096's feet getting deeper and deeper
and deeper as the walls rose taller and
taller around it the creature wailed
until a tide of the awful stuff reached
its face and cascaded down its throat
melting all the organs within as the
creature was fully submerged scp-106
manifested atop the wall and looked down
smiling spitefully he thought oh you may
have had me there
but in the end
i always win
nothing could survive that and yet
bubbles still rose from the slot below
the old man gritted his rotten teeth and
balled his fists in quiet anger moments
later back in our dimension a portal
opened in the ground of
scp-096's containment chamber it vomited
out scp-096's skeleton smothered in
bubbling black goo and scp-106
096 would probably be fully regenerated
within a couple of hours and if 682's
encounter with him was anything to go by
probably extremely unwilling to
interface with the old man and the old
man himself who couldn't help but feel a
little humiliated by the whole
experience was glad the two of them
would probably never meet again he left
the regenerating 096 and commenced the
walk of shame back to his containment
chamber they didn't even need the femur
breaker he just felt like having a sit
down and processing it all nobody else
would ever know what happened in the
pocket dimension that day and for the
old man's pride that was probably for
the best but he'd know he'd always know
by the night's end he was sitting in his
containment chamber again for lornly
wondering god damn old timer have you
lost your age
what do you do when the sun turns wrong
when light which once represented life
joy and warmth becomes a symbol of death
and destruction do you hide inside
shutter the windows keep out the light
by any means necessary do you retreat
underground where the sun's rays cannot
penetrate burrowing into the dark and
the cold do you simply give yourself to
it accepting that there is no escaping
something so vast so far reaching as
sunlight itself and allow yourself to be
lost in the end of all things we've
covered this possibility before
scp-001 when daybreaks or sd lock's
proposal it's difficult to know what any
given person might do in such harrowing
circumstances after all we have always
learned to love the light and fear the
darkness it turns our very understanding
of reality upside down to have that
paradigm shifted the dark becoming
safety and the light becoming death the
source of all life on earth of all
warmth transforming in an instant from
the sun as we know it to a
napoleon-class scp that melts all living
organisms that cross into its gaze but
what about a being that has always
feared the light something that
prioritizes solitude and never ever
wants to be seen how might it live out
those darkened days today we're taking a
look at what happens when daybreak meets
a familiar face even if a constantly
hidden one scp-096
scp-096 or the shy guy is something of a
celebrity around here it is a humanoid
creature with long distended arms pale
skin and a jaw that can open four times
wider than an ordinary humans there is
only one thing above all else that this
entity desires for no one to see its
face when someone views its face it
flies into an uncontrollable rage and
seems to have no other option but to
destroy the person who has seen it so it
is unlikely that a creature so intent on
solitude would be in much danger from
the transformed sun in fact it might
even be a positive thing and for some
time it was with so many human beings
gone reduced to gelatinous masses with
no desire but to slither around in the
ghoulish sunlight and merge with one
another there were fewer people to
observe his face than ever he could stay
inside and know with almost complete
certainty that no one would come to
bother him no one was coming to look at
him and there were no more visitors
researchers poking and prodding that
might sneak a look at his face and so he
stayed there in the room that had served
as his containment unit before the world
turned upside down the masses of flesh
that once were humans did not concern
him as they never looked at his face all
he did was stay in his room and never go
outside the outside frightened him
terribly though he was not concerned
with the deadly sunlight or the
possibility of it melting him as it had
so many others he was much more afraid
that someone some unlikely survivor
clinging to their original life might
look at him that they might see his face
that was simply too distressing to risk
he would much rather stay alone in his
old cell weeping softly in the shadows
one day though we couldn't say how many
days after the end of things it had been
he was weeping alone in his former cell
the days blurred together spent the same
way and time had lost much of its
meaning through the echoing sound of his
sobs and the sloshing sounds of the
creatures outside a woman's voice cut
through it was faint but he could make
out what she was saying she was calling
out for help asking if anyone had any
food or fresh water the sound was
getting louder closer accompanied by the
disconcerting thump of her footsteps she
was coming down the hall
as much as it could be called a hall
anymore she was coming towards his room
to disrupt his miserable peace he heard
her steps crossed the threshold of his
room and her voice broke into a
terrified scream no doubt at the
unexpected sight of a pale naked
creature weeping in the corner of what
she expected to be an empty room
startled by the first loud sound he'd
heard in a long time in a world that had
mostly been silent since the initial
outpouring of agonized screams had faded
into the soft slap of flesh and slime on
the ground he turned around he shouldn't
ordinarily he wouldn't but he couldn't
stop himself there he saw a woman wide
eyes filled with tears face streaked
with dirt a small child next to her
holding her hand and clinging to her leg
just as he saw the woman she saw him she
saw his face
anger boiled over inside of him and he
let out a scream
wild primal and filled with inhuman rage
she could not be looking at him seeing
his face he couldn't let her the woman
ran with the child in tow panicked by
the wild roar and the sight of him
standing upright before her the anger
faded as she left his sight making her
way down the hall into the stairs but
then he remembered she had seen his face
he could not let her leave it was time
to do something he never thought he'd
have to do again hunt his heightened
senses picked up the sound of muffled
footsteps coming up through the floor
below him she was downstairs just
beneath the floor where he was standing
his instincts kicked in and his body
moved almost of its own accord he lifted
his long long arms above his head and
drove his hands down into the floor it
was weakened by the ravages of the
elements and time and crumbled under his
unnatural strength he dug his claws into
the plaster tearing it apart and
cracking it into pieces he pushed his
claws in deeper and deeper until he
could feel them breaking through the
other side he pulled the floor apart
until the hole was wide enough to fit
through then dropped down to the room
below he spotted the woman's back
fleeing through the door just as he
landed she was getting away he tore
after her ripping through concrete and
steel destroying everything in his path
in a mad dash for the object of his rage
he had to catch her she could not be
allowed to leave she looked over her
shoulder at him her face a mask of pure
terror she knew just as he knew that
there was no escape in sight in his
single-minded obsession and her
desperation to escape from him neither
of them noticed that she had run so far
and so carelessly that she was now
outside the building she had crossed
from the shadows into the harsh light of
the sun the woman's eyes widened in grim
understanding of her fate he could only
watch helplessly as her body began to
succumb to the vicious rays almost
instantly she began to melt as it was
closest to the sun her head was the
first to go her nose drooped like hot
wax dripping as it went until it slumped
off her face
and landed on the ground with a
sickening splash her eyes were next
popping out of their sockets and hanging
loose and limp on her cheeks and
dangling from sinewy strands she tried
in vain to stuff them back into place
but they squished in her hands like over
ripe fruit she attempted to run into the
comparative safety of the ruined
building but her feet were already
beginning to spread out onto the street
melting into a sticky red smear on the
pavement her legs crumbled beneath her
and she collapsed to the ground her face
leaving a trail of gelatinous flesh as
it landed she tried uselessly to drag
herself along the ground back into the
darkness but her arms were melting into
the dirt mixing with it into a horrible
red mud she let out a last scream of
agony but the sound turned to a thick
gurgle as her lips fused together and
her mouth melted into nothingness he
watched it all sobbing and roaring in
frustration she was gone and he would
never get the satisfaction of ending her
the infernal son had stolen her from him
now she was nothing but a wet shadow
like the rest of the humans had become
long ago he heard the sound of a soft
sob behind him a tiny human voice he
turned looking for the source there was
the little girl he had almost forgotten
about her she was calling out for her
mother and crying and she was looking
right at him right at his face he waited
for the anger to overtake him but
instead there was nothing why wasn't he
angry she was looking at his face so why
then he realized her eyes were on him
but she did not see him she was blind
she approached the creature her arms
outstretched following the sound of his
crying she touched his hand with her own
tiny fingers so small and fragile and
asked mommy then he felt something he
had never felt before tenderness care a
desire to protect this tiny innocent
being it was the first time he had ever
felt warm he ever felt anything but
sadness anger or fear overcome with his
softness he wrapped his arms around the
child and hugged her close she hugged
him back tightly and the room went quiet
as they both stopped crying from that
day on they became a family of sorts
they lived together and he took care of
her she didn't know what he looked like
and had no idea he might be something to
fear to her he was safety he was home
for the first time in his long awful
life he felt like a human instead of a
monster he would scavenge food for her
bring her fresh water lay down stolen
blankets and pillows so she would have a
soft place to rest he even found her a
ratty worn teddy bear amongst the rubble
and gave it to her as a gift she
clutched it to her chest and thanked him
and for once his tears were those of joy
in this cursed world they had found
something like happiness in one another
he knew he would protect her no matter
what then one day everything changed
the creature and the little girl were
playing in the abandoned site making up
little games together when he took a
break to look out at the window and
monitor their surroundings outside the
evil red sun waited when he turned back
the little girl was gone one of the
shadowy creatures once human was
imitating his voice to lure her away he
could hear it in the distance and her
tiny footsteps following it he chased
after her the only thing he had ever
loved and saw her just as she stepped
out into the light she screamed as one
of her arms began to melt in the light
and he knew what he had to do he grabbed
her and pulled her back inside using his
body to shield her from the horrible
rays as he wept over her his tears
stopped her body from melting any
further but his body continued to fall
apart it was too late for him he ran as
far as he could once he transformed he
did not want to end up hurting the girl
he ran until his legs melted away and he
could not run anymore he had reached the
shoreline and stared out of the ocean
unable to move anymore he screamed a
final time in agony in heartbreak in
mourning for the happiness he had
finally found and now would lose but at
least he knew as his eyes melted away
and he was nearly gone that the girl
would be safe and then he was gone and
the world was quiet
a very strange anomaly sits in a
humanoid containment cell in the minimum
security wing of site-17 he walks talks
and looks like a man but everything else
is convoluted in a question mark this is
scp-343 who like his namesake god is
likely to cause arguments whenever he's
brought up is he the creator of all that
exists the basis for the abrahamic
faiths or is he a pretender a reality
warper with immense power and
predilection towards delusion a
courtesan of the house of maladrog
matthew methuselah yahweh who knows
really it depends on who you ask and
which stories you choose to believe and
few people enjoy a good story more than
scp-343 himself if one day you take the
time to visit him in his room and ask
him to reveal a page in the long book of
his personal history he might be kind
enough to tell you a story a story like
this of an encounter with something
monstrous that few others could hope to
survive meeting face to face rewind a
few thousand years nobody knows how many
exactly god as he chooses to dub himself
walked across the cracked ground on worn
sandals it'd been some time since he'd
seen an animal around here and even
longer since he'd seen a human being not
that this bothered him he'd never been
bothered by his own company on a long
walk like this of course he could have
sped up time or teleported but where was
the fun in that he was a tourist in the
world of sensation of experience of
flesh bone dirt blood and sand after all
where's the fun in creating a whole
universe if you can't drop in now and
then to visit and do as the romans do
not that the romans would be around for
another few thousand years even atlas
must occasionally shift the weight of
the globe from his shoulders for a jaunt
around the cosmic neighborhood and
whatever passes for fresh air in the
vacuum god whistled the tune to himself
it was a craggy mountainous region he'd
found himself in the distant peaks had
frosted caps a breath taking place where
many truly had their breaths taken away
how humans will so happily risk their
lives to do something extraordinary it
never ceased to amaze him his stomach
rumbled oh how he enjoyed that sensation
one of the funny little quirks of this
human form that he weaved for himself it
was no reason to be concerned if memory
served from his last trip through the
area a few decades before there was a
friendly village not far from here they
had always accepted him as a genial
stranger having no knowledge of his true
power god had always believed that a
person's goodness is defined by how they
treat those from whom they had nothing
to gain so it caused him great concern
as he approached the village and saw
great plumes of smoke rising into the
sky he was so shocked by this that he
could decide to break his rule about
walking as a man in case there was still
some way he could help with a snap of
his fingers he disappeared and
reappeared in the center of the
village's town square total devastation
huts and houses had been torn asunder
broken weapons lay on the ground some
places were on fire others smeared with
streaks of blood like some terrible
battle had occurred here
but something was wrong no bodies not
one from defender or assailant how could
a thriving village be so thoroughly
destroyed and not leave a single corpse
it was an act so bizarre and depraved
that it left even god puzzling that was
another downside of his human form here
on earth he didn't have access to true
omniscience how could a mere human mind
bound by the constraints of linear time
ever truly comprehend the total of
existence even attempting to do that
here would melt the brain of his human
body in its skull and leave it dribbling
out of his nose and ears instead he
chose to walk around the ruins of the
village and investigate first hand
arrows and broken spears and swords
littered the ground some buildings were
demolished but there were no tracks or
stray projectiles that could suggest the
presence of siege weapons now these
buildings look like they were ripped
apart some even still had claw marks
what terrible beast could have set upon
this town and done this then he heard a
voice quiet and pleading beneath some
nearby rubble a survivor he rushed over
to the pile and evaporated it with a
thought underneath a feeble old man
covered in stone dust was quivering god
helped him up and guided him into one of
the few remaining huts still standing in
the village they both took seats god
held up two hands cradling empty space
two cups suddenly occupied that space
both filled with warm healing tea he
passed the old man one of the cops while
sipping from his own he asked the old
man if he'd seen what had happened the
old man told him no he hadn't seen
anything in decades he'd been rendered
blind in his youth little did either of
them know that very blindness was the
only reason he was the sole survivor of
the massacre the blind man told god that
one of the village's scouts had gone up
into the mountain with a small hunting
party the group was gone for days until
one of the members the youngest among
them returned weeping frost bitten and
covered in blood he said that his
friends had been killed by a beast in
the mountains something that almost
looked like a man but terribly wrong and
its face its awful awful face he would
never forget it he was just lucky to
escape with his life when the others
were torn apart but when the young man
returned he brought the shadow of death
with him it was a curse that doomed the
entire village men woman and children to
a terrible fate and that fate was upon
them a mere hour after the survivor had
returned of course there were gaps in
the blind man's understanding given he
was lacking one of his major senses but
the sounds he could describe with
perfect clarity it was faint and distant
at first that awful whale and the
galloping hands and feet thundering
against the ground faster than any horse
could move getting closer and closer
another villager saw it approaching and
screamed then it was upon them the
villagers screamed but it screamed
louder always wailing and shrieking and
sobbing like a monster crawling straight
up from hell people tried to fight it by
the sounds of it the blind man with
teary blank eyes recalled the sounds of
arrows knocking and swords clashing
against something but even their
greatest warriors had screamed and died
those who saw it and tried to flee and
hide were slaughtered all the same soon
enough there were only two sounds left
in the village the monster and the blind
man both weeping he didn't understand
why it never took him it wasn't fair it
took everything else to leave him here
alive when everyone and everything he'd
ever known was destroyed was a greater
punishment than even death after killing
all of these innocents the monster had
simply wandered off to the mountains
again the sound of its quiet sobs
getting smaller and smaller until it was
gone altogether
god comforted the blind man as he wept
for the loss of all his loved ones he
told the blind man that he would venture
up to the mountains himself and confront
the creature on its own territory and at
the very least find out why it had done
this terrible thing but first he must
relocate the blind man to a safer place
he placed a hand on the blind man's
shoulder and he vanished he would appear
in another friendly village miles away
god sent a silent message into the minds
of every villager take good care of this
man
he has undergone horrors you can't even
imagine
your kindness will be rewarded later for
that
you have my promise
god sighed and turned his tired eyes to
the distant mountains a monster lurked
up there perhaps one of his own
creations or maybe a corruption of one
of his creations either way whatever
existed without his knowledge existed
without his consent and he intended to
know of the beast in the mountains
though given what he'd seen already he
didn't expect to receive a warm welcome
from this murderous demon miles away up
in the mountains the creature licked the
blood from its cracked lips it looked
like it might have once been a human
being or something that aspired to
humanity or mocked it with its very
existence it was a huge gangling beast
skin alablaster eyes empty and soulless
dribbling rivulets of burning tears down
a hideous gaunt face he crawled into the
frozen mouth of a cave with great icicle
fangs wheezing and weeping all it ever
wanted was to be alone why did they have
to keep interfering didn't they know
what happened all the terrible things
they made it do the creature curled its
long gangly body into the fetal position
scratching great ruts into the sides of
its bald cranium with long sharp fingers
terrible things terrible terrible things
and then there was a brilliant flash
just a few feet away the monster was
surprised he'd turned to see a figure
silhouetted in the mouth of the cave he
wore sandals and thin robes his eyes
glowed with a kind of power that the
monster didn't recognize this stranger
stared at the monster without an ounce
of fear in his heart he stared right
into its eyes unwavering no no no no no
he could feel it again the rage bubbling
up deep down a cauldron of seething
anger it hated the feeling like being
lowered into a vat of molten metal
unspeakable fire and pain coursing
through every vessel he began to weep
and scream while the stranger in the
cave mouth just watched not moving a
muscle do you know who i am
the stranger asked with a deep voice
that betrayed almost infinite power
knowledge and wisdom but it wouldn't
change the outcome here the monster
bounded at him at speeds that wouldn't
be seen again until jet planes and
bullet trains are invented millennia
into the future its jaws were hanging
impossibly wide fangs born its arms
extended and deadly claws ready to
strike but before those terrible hands
could close around the stranger he
vanished the monster stumbled and rolled
across the snow confused what trickery
was being used here i'll take that as a
no
said the voice from behind him you want
to show your father some respect more
respect than you gave to those poor
people down in the village at least
seething the creature turned and saw the
stranger standing back in the darkness
of the cave staring at him but the beast
didn't have the capacity for awe or holy
terror only violence boundless limitless
unstoppable violence it darted towards
the stranger again trying to strike him
somehow it was like fighting an empty
robe not a single one of its deadly
strikes seemed to hit the stranger the
stranger leaped backwards putting some
space between himself and the monster
but still not breaking the sweat he
breathed in deeply then exhaled the
breath came out like a mighty typhoon
shocking even the monster with its
sudden force it was blown backwards a
leaf in the wind until its long claws
dug into the ground and anchored it in
place the stranger gave a wry smile at
this impressed my mind you're certainly
a tenacious one aren't you
he said perhaps we can talk for a little
while instead of fighting
i want to know why you killed all those
people
no answer the beast roared its mighty
limbs pounding into the ground as it
closed the gap between itself and the
stranger in fractions of a second it
would kill him rend him destroy him just
like all the others he'd left it no
choice suddenly the ground below it
seemed to give way the creature was
confused it looked down to see that the
ancient stone below had somehow taken on
the properties of a liquid and it was
sinking the beast panicked and it began
to thrash it was a strong swimmer but it
didn't expect to need to swim here the
shock was too much and soon the ground
submerged it entirely muffling its
terrible roars and shrieks and just like
that the ground was solid again trapping
the beast inside the stranger stepped
forward and looked at the ground a much
needed timeout
he said you do yourself no good
struggling like this
despite its terrible capacity for evil
god couldn't help but admire the beast
at least on the level of construction it
was so pared down so unburdened a killer
to the core but seemingly unkillable had
he made this creature billions of
species and the species those in turn
had created through billions of years of
breeding and evolution and somewhere
along the line this thing happened it
was easy even for the universe's creator
to lose track of some of the tinier
variables and in the grand scheme of
things even this monster was still a
tiny variable but right here right now
it was still one hell of a problem the
ground rumbled below god cracks formed
the mountain peak shook god raised an
eyebrow genuinely impressed as the
monster ripped free of its stone prison
and re-entered the fray it roared and
screamed still its blank eyes fixed on
him his skeletal body throbbed and
heaved with power unlike any other
creature in nature it was almost like
the longer their conflict went on the
more energized the beast became god's
side all those poor villagers they never
stood a chance against this monster it
lunged for him even faster and stronger
than before he teleported out of the way
in the nick of time and the beast's
claws cleaved through a nearby cave wall
effortless god materialized nearby but
he didn't have time to speak the beast
lunged again and again and again
every time he reappeared the beast went
for him with impossible speed deciding
to widen the playing field god
teleported to the top of the mountain
the creature somehow sensing his
presence vaulted upwards and tunneled
through the roof of the cave bursting
out of the ground in front of god who
was floating just slightly off the
ground it would be wise of you to stop
god carefully in toned all this time you
know i've been going easy on you
you don't want to find out what the
wrath of god looks like storm clouds
were gathering above mighty thunder
roared across the sky the beast was
undeterred it roared and galloped
towards god and god in turn called down
a response a volley of lightning the
likes of which the world has never seen
before or since struck down on the
charging monster the sudden white flash
could sting the eyes from miles away the
monster shrieked from the blast feeling
its flesh lift off its bones and atomize
in the sheer heat of the electricity
around it it could smell itself cooking
the lightning blast only lasted for a
few seconds but for the beast it felt
like eternity when the onslaught stopped
the air was still heavy with electrical
potential god stared down at the black
scorch mark on the side of the mountain
where the creature had been standing all
the snow within a mile had been
evaporated by the blast it was a raw
display of the power of nature that
would make even zeus tremble in his
sandals and yet
there was still movement something
started to get up from the burnt patch
where nothing should be left alive a
blackened skeleton rising shakily from
the ash but still very much alive as it
started to rise new flesh began growing
over its bones little by little even god
was astonished by the sight of it he'd
never seen a creature clinging so
ardently to life in spite of having
truly unsurmountable power amassed
against it it was up against god and
still it fought the monster tottered on
its freakishly long limbs still
disoriented unusually staggered for a
creature driven by such single-minded
violent purpose when enough of its face
grew back to do so it began to weep and
sob again tears streaking down its
terrible face looking at this creature
after all of this god couldn't help but
feel a new emotion pity he lowered
himself to the ground and approached the
creature like none had ever done before
he gathered it up into his arms and he
held it feeling its heaving wretched
sobs against him the beast was in so
much pain he could feel it radiating
from within
speak muslim
god said in a soft fatherly voice and
for the first and only time the monster
spoke
[Applause]
please
that was all it managed to choke out
before devolving back into
unintelligible babble but it was enough
enough for god to understand its pain he
did not know if it would be right to
change the monster's nature is it ever
right to truly change anyone's nature
but it was within his almost limitless
power to grant it one reprieve from pain
he settled the beast in the snow below
him it was quiet and still and god said
unto the beast rest now child
rest for thousands of years if you must
i hope only that when you eventually
awaken
you feel
differently and so another story from
the catalog of scp-343
of course it leaves us with certain
questions chief among them being is it
true did 343 and 096 have this chance
encounter long ago or is this just
another tall tale from an anomaly who
fancies himself a deity we have our
truth and you have yours if you've been
a close follower of this channel for a
while now or even of the scp foundation
archive as a whole then there's a pretty
high chance that you might have heard of
scp-096
even if this just so happens to be the
first of rscp videos that you've ever
clicked on you still might have seen the
shy guy itself in various other corners
of the internet since the earliest days
of the scp foundation
scp-096 has gradually become one of the
most iconic and recognizable creatures
in the foundation's entire menagerie of
anomalous beings despite standing taller
than any ordinary person you might be
forgiven for mistaking scp-096 for a
human being if you were to see it at a
distance but the creature is unusually
proportioned to say the least still
appearing almost human in its shape but
possessing long dangling arms that
almost reach the ground
scp-096's body is thin and hairless with
opaque clear white pupillus eyes and a
wide gaping mouth or so we've heard
thanks to drawings provided by someone
who sadly isn't with us anymore but you
might be surprised to learn that scp-096
doesn't really do all that much mostly
the tall spindly humanoid spends its
days walking mindlessly pacing around in
its containment cell sounds like most
days in a college dorm during lockdown
right that is of course until someone
dares to look at
scp-096's face it doesn't have to be
directly either it can be something as
simple as glancing at a photo or
watching a video of the creature but the
moment it is seen the exact second it is
perceived the wiry monster will know
having its face viewed in any way will
cause the shy guy to really live up to
its nickname the creature suffers some
sort of psychological meltdown covering
its face with its huge claw-like hands
and weeping
scp-096 quickly becomes utterly
inconsolable suffering from extreme
emotional distress until it simply can't
take it anymore pulling itself up to its
full looming height
scp-096 will stand and travel at
impossible speeds towards the person
that dared look at its face there's no
way to hide from the shy guy nothing can
stand in its path as it tracks down this
unlucky person and when it finds them
well it's certainly not pleasant somehow
without leaving any trace on their body
scp-096 will kill the person that looked
at it possibly even eating them
afterwards then it calms itself down
returns to its more docile state and is
typically bagged and brought back home
by whatever mobile task force is closest
scp-096 has killed many of the teams
sent to contain it proving itself to be
resistant to gunfire and any forms of
conventional weaponry as much as being
only a tiny speck in a photograph that
is enough to trigger the creature's
relentless defense mechanism nobody can
get away from it either there is
literally nowhere in the entire world
that someone can run to escape
scp-096 not even crossing the oceans or
jumping aboard a plane is enough to stop
it and if our community questions video
on the matter is anything to go by you
may not even be safe in outer space the
scp foundation's only real way to keep
the creature safely under wraps and
contained is to lock it up and force all
members of personnel to never ever look
at it while they hunt down any pieces of
recorded media still out there waiting
like a ticking time bomb so if no member
of the foundation can look at scp-096
how do they interact with it well
luckily there's a tale that answers
exactly that known as a lesson in power
dr danielle kowalski a member of the
foundation's research team assigned to
scp-096 was sent into the creature's
cell wearing a sleep mask you know the
kind you get on expensive flights what
she was really wishing for though was a
gas mask to go with it nobody had warned
her how bad scp-096
smelled then again few had been as close
to the creature as she had and lived to
tell the tale as a child danielle
kowalski had a fear of stepping into the
ocean her mother used to warn her about
treading on a stingray and dying as a
result giving her a phobia that stayed
with her for many years but danielle's
father had encouraged her to face her
fear to shuffle her feet on the ocean
floor kicking up sand so that the
stingray would know she was coming and
would simply just swim away perhaps if
he could have seen what kind of horrors
danielle was working with at the
foundation her father wouldn't have
tried to make her so fearless maybe
there are some things that it's logical
to be afraid of entering scp-096's cell
dr kowalski could hear the monster's
heaving breaths the perfect mix between
a frightened whimper and a death rattle
the haunting sound of a person's final
gasp of air in the back of her mind
danielle hoped she didn't touch the
creature by accident the closer she got
the tension and the heat of its warm
breath against her skin was making the
approach all the more terrifying she had
been issued with an instant camera and
took a photo in the dark click the flash
fired but with her eyes covered she
couldn't tell that was good though that
was the point if danielle could see the
flash going off she could see what else
was in the room and that would put her
in even more danger she was locked in
with a kind of stingray that wouldn't
swim away even if it knew she was there
slowly dr kowalski began blindly
photographing the cell around her
stuffing each freshly printed photo into
her pocket as the camera spat them out
over the span of 45 minutes she took a
series of pictures of the entire cell
until the film in the instant camera had
run out danielle knew that she would
probably only need one picture but
better to have more just in case luckily
none of her foundation colleagues were
around to tell her how insane what she
was doing actually was they were all
preoccupied preparing the site for its
first official visit from the fbi this
all took place after what was known as
the broken masquerade had taken place
essentially knowledge of the scp
foundation and its research into the
endless stream of anomalies it had
contained was all made public people
knew the truth now and the foundation
found itself in the one place it never
wanted to be the public eye the
organization and its activities were
under the scrutiny of every journalist
on the planet and once more information
about the scps and the anomalous world
of the foundation became known the world
would surely change forever danielle
kowalski knew all of this and told
herself that everyone would need
something for protection now she only
hoped her photographs would be enough
fifteen months later dr kowalski was
interrogated in her apartment by one
agent o'brien he and a group of fellow
agents had barged into danielle's home
demanding to know the location where a
number of scp-610 specimens were being
held scp-610 being of course the
infamous infection known as the flesh
that hates a disease capable of turning
human beings into horrible deformed
monstrosities of flesh agent o'brien and
presumably whoever he was working for
was intent on turning these creatures
into weapons and the man had little
patience for a former foundation
researcher who wasn't giving up the
answers that he wanted danielle tried to
argue with the agent citing the berlin
accords against weaponized anomalies a
motion proposed to the united states
senate that would forbid the use of
anomalous objects entities and creatures
as weapons for any country o'brien
wasn't interested he claimed that if the
kremlin in russia had no intention of
ratifying such a law then america
wouldn't either the agent had his men
grab danielle by her arm while he
grabbed her right middle finger and
began to push a thin knife under her
fingernail the former member of the
foundation tried to stifle her screen
but couldn't stop herself as the pain
struck as agent o'brien tortured
danielle he told her that the russians
had all the information they would need
about
scp-610 in order to turn the flesh into
some kind of weapon as far as he was
concerned the united states government
needed access to those scp-610 specimens
to know exactly what they would be up
against in the likely event that russia
used the flesh that hates against them
and only a researcher for the scp
foundation the former senior researcher
on the scp-610 project would know where
to find those specimens you don't think
it's reasonable for the united states
government to want to understand what
could be used against us o'brien asked
as danielle's blood trickled out of her
finger into his leather gloves
hell i don't care what you think we're
gonna do with it i want those specimens
when the agent finally let her go dr
kowalski tried to catch her breath
forcing herself not to scream in pain
again she pointed with her other
unharmed hand to her bedroom telling
o'brien to check the bottom left drawer
she had placed a manila envelope in
there containing the only thing danielle
had kept since departing the scp
foundation under o'brien's orders his
men ransacked the nearby room and were
quickly able to find what they were
looking for the envelope was presented
to agent o'brien who was no doubt
expecting to find a file inside
something that detailed the exact
location of those specimens he was
looking for so you can probably imagine
the dissatisfied look on his face when
he opened the envelope to find
photographs a collection of instant
photos all taken in a dark cell with all
of them depicting a tall thin humanoid
creature a being with long dangling arms
that almost reached the ground a thin
hairless body opaque pupillous eyes and
a wide gaping mouth furious to once
again be denied the information he was
looking for o'brien disregarded the
pictures and burned dr kowalski's neck
with his cigarette in his anger he said
i think your foundation sure thought
they were powerful hiding in the shadows
but i'd like to explain to you why
you're wrong the agent then went on to
describe his time as a member of the dea
in the late 1980s and how he'd been
involved in the hunting of notorious
cartel boss pablo escobar i had a narco
in custody every bit as uncooperative as
you are now the man had insisted that
escobar owned all the colombian law
enforcement but a younger o'brien had
argued that if that was the case and
they possessed all this power then why
did pablo escobar's men hide their guns
why smuggle drugs in secret and bury
their money where no one would find it
if they really had the control they
claimed much like escobar's cartel the
scp foundation had always moved in the
shadows a power that o'brien believed to
have really belonged to the government
your anomalies belong to us your
research belongs to us your life
belongs to us he told dr kowalski
suddenly one of the other agents noticed
movement outside of the apartment the
second that danielle saw a long arm face
through her wall with grey skin like
that of a corpse she snapped her eyes
shut o'brien and his men drew all their
guns and opened fire on the monster that
had walked through the wall as if it
wasn't even there all the while danielle
kowalski kept her eyes shut the sounds
of screaming and snapping bones and a
sickening slurping noise filled the air
but she made sure not to look within a
few quick moments of panic and agonizing
pain it was over the apartment was quiet
apart from strange breathing like a mix
of a frightening whimper and a death
rattle run along now zero nine six dr
kowalski told the shy guy there are
worse monsters in this world than you dr
dan anxiously paced in his cell it was
the only way he'd been able to occupy
himself for the past six months saved
for pouring through files and when he
was lucky being able to oversee another
failed termination attempt he only
stopped pacing gwen for a brief and
horrible moment he realized that monster
was probably doing the exact same thing
in its big metal cube at this very
moment that horrible creature that he'd
thrown away his life for a futile shot
at killing perhaps the whole thing had
been a fool's errand after all he was
formerly a researcher under the employee
of the scp foundation secure contain
protect they had truly sadistic beasts
like
scp-106 the nightmarish old man and
scp-352 baba yaga in containment cells
and there was no plans to terminate
either of them they weren't the global
occult coalition for 343's sake why did
dr dan even want to terminate
scp-096 in the first place he tried to
explain it to them again and again but
his pleas had fallen on deaf ears in his
mind the impetus for destroying the shy
guy was terrifyingly clear it was a
monster that killed anyone or anything
that looked at its face even a
photograph of it even a tiny collection
of pixels when its rage state was
induced it seemed that nothing would
stop it it would have an intuitive
psychic link to its victim charge at
them at breakneck speed and only find it
zen again once all of them were dead and
if a picture of
scp-096 was leaked onto the internet it
would cause a chain reaction that
triggered an xk class and the world
scenario there were plenty of creatures
and entities that the foundation knew
about that could theoretically bring
about the apocalypse but to him 096 was
the most realistic it preyed upon the
inherent curiosity and thirst for
knowledge seated in every human heart
the same drive to simply know that led
to the creation of the scp foundation
would be humanity's doom in the face of
an
scp-096 outbreak and if such a thing
happened the foundation would need to
break the masquerade of secrecy to have
any hope of saving humanity in his many
feverish nightmares dr dan had seen it
all so clearly the first photographs of
scp-096's face would be leaked online
perhaps a few hundred people across the
globe would look in disparate enough
locations that it would be almost
impossible for the foundation to detect
and save all of them as
scp-096 went on its bloody rampage of
course as the image proliferated as
images on the internet often do the
purview of 096's violence would only
grow people across the nation would
start to take notice and soon after that
across the world mysterious creature
causing mass casualties would be the
headline on every news desk because why
would anybody want to talk about
anything else perhaps some foolish
reporters would take video footage of
the creature everyone has a phone these
days with high definition cameras
pictures would be taken and posted more
and more of it would flood the internet
too many simultaneous moles for even the
scp foundation to whack the news would
spread panic and hysteria would spread
people wouldn't even know what's
triggering all this horror if the
foundation didn't go public and tell
them that it was the pictures that was
killing everyone and by then wouldn't it
already be too late the antidote to fear
is knowledge it's why when anything goes
wrong we're refreshing timelines and
feeds and news websites for any kind of
information and if you were told an
unstoppable monster was killing scores
of people and might be coming to a
neighborhood near you sometime soon
wouldn't you want a good look at it
wouldn't you want to know your enemy
having no idea that the mere act of
knowing was what sealed your horrible
fate by dr dan's bleak estimations if
only several million people died as a
result of this kind of scenario it could
be considered a positive outcome he'd
seen it all but no matter how many times
he tried to articulate this to his
superiors he wasn't listened to they
didn't take him or the threat that
scp-096 posed seriously every time he
warned of the apocalyptic potential of
scp-096
he was simply told to get back to
working on those goggles it was why he
needed to give those naysayers a
demonstration it was why a certain
photograph needed to show up in the home
of a certain mountaineer it's why all
those people had to die there was no
other way the deaths of the civilians
and the researchers and the mobile task
force members were of course regrettable
but it was the only way to prevent the
deaths of so many more they gave him
what he wanted permission to put this
gangly time bomb in the ground even if
the beast's death was inextricably tied
to his own execution at the hands of the
very employers who authorized him the
world was full of funny little ironies
like that another one is that even
though dr dan now had the authorization
and funding to terminate scp-096
he was discovering that he lacked
another important factor the capability
they tried incinerating it exposing it
to massive amounts of radiation exposing
it to an insane degree of kinetic trauma
the equivalent of being hit by an out of
control bullet train they tested every
kind of experimental off the books
weaponry that they had access to through
various research projects proton blasts
lasers high intensity energy beams
nothing even when they fried off every
scrap of flesh on the monster's body its
unbreakable skeletons still remained and
in what seemed like no time at all it'd
be back in action its very existence
seemed to mock him a guard opened his
cell door staring disdainfully at the
disgraced researcher that same guard had
slammed his head against a wall a month
earlier one of his friends had
apparently been killed in the legendary
096 containment breach that set this
whole sword thing in motion up an atom
scumbag he said in the gruff surly voice
training a handgun on the doctor he knew
wouldn't fight back they need you in
test chamber 6. dr dan allowed himself a
small grin imperceptible to the guard
who clearly hated his guts they'd
approved his 096 versus 682 cross test
marvelous how marvelous to all the
others it would seem like just one more
entry in a long line of 682 cross tests
he thought it darkly funny in his eyes
the foundation had no hope of ever
killing
scp-682 its defining quality was being
impossible to kill and it didn't present
nearly the threat to the entire world
that 096 posed
their futile attempts to murder the
lizard were little more than a money
sink to justify the site's exorbitant
funding but perhaps he could turn this
to his benefit maybe
scp-682 would hold the secret to
actually killing off his nemesis within
30 hours dr dan had his disappointing
answer both anomalies had undeniably
done a real number on each other and dr
dan did take a kind of sick amusement in
the mental trauma that scp-682 had
induced in zero nine sex but ultimately
it was all for nothing 682 had skin 096
alive and melted off its flesh with acid
but once again that indestructible
skeleton stood firm this had been the
27th termination attempt since the
incident the 27th failed termination
attempt dr dan mentally corrected
himself 096's skeleton kept defeating
them even their most ardent attempts to
penetrate the bones and destroy the
creature within had failed during a
previous attempt they tried to access
the brain by putting a diamond hard
drill into its eye sockets of course it
was the drill that actually broke much
to dr dan's seemingly tireless
frustration needless to say in the
debriefing interview with dr carver a
researcher who once would have
considered him a colleague he wasn't in
high spirits if he managed to kill this
thing then he would always be the hero
who made a terrible sacrifice in order
to save many more lives if he didn't
kill 096 he was little more than the
monster who murdered all those innocent
people for nothing though you'd never
hear him say it out loud if it wasn't
for that damnable indestructible
skeleton this monster would be long dead
already if only there was some way to
break the creature's bones that's when
it hit him scp-173
the sculpture a site-19 icon often
overlooked because of its more silent
but deadly style but undeniably one of
the most frightening and dangerous
anomalies out there it had racked up a
truly shocking body count since it was
first interred at site 19 in 1993
one broken neck at a time and it's one
of the few creatures out there that even
the hard to destroy reptile himself is
utterly terrified of perhaps a monster
that practically has a phd in breaking
bones would be the ideal candidate to
vandalize the shy guy's vertebrae once
his proposal was greenlit for initial
testing dr dan arranged for the shy guy
with a bag over his head of course to be
brought into a testing chamber with the
ever stoic
scp-173 when all the researchers and
guards were safely outside all it took
was a single blink to make all of dr
dan's darkest dreams come true in the
nanoseconds his eyes were closed he
heard the most beautiful sounds in the
world a loud fleshy crunch and a pained
howl from 096 he opened his eyes to an
equally wondrous sight 096 doubled over
at an unnatural angle its spine snapped
between the 4th and 5th vertebrae spinal
fluid leaking down the creature's flank
that freaky little sculpture had done it
it had actually damaged the integrity of
the shy guy's skeleton it was at that
moment that dr dan knew he could kill
this thing admittedly there was a
containment breach shortly after that
when the bag slipped off of 096's head
and it charged through the nearby steel
wall killing multiple people before
being subdued and recontained but when
it comes to projects involving dr dan a
mere handful of innocent people being
killed sits comfortably within the
acceptable margin of error a day later
dr dan was standing before a crowded
boardroom with agents researchers and
even a few members of the o5 council in
attendance he explained his findings to
them and the fact that even more
importantly they may have a way to bring
the wretched existence of 096 to an
absolute halt his plans were approved
not long after he was putting them into
motion dr dan was surrounded by
researchers and heavily armed guards as
173 was escorted into the test chamber
with a forklift 096 was there still
bagged off to the side was a giant tub
of hydrofluoric acid connected to a hose
and injector attachment if this didn't
work nothing would everyone stood back
in a safe zone as 173 was released to do
its thing crunch just like the previous
time 096's spine had been successfully
snapped spinal fluid dribbled down its
skin everyone had rushed into the
chamber one group kept 173 isolated with
their stairs the other headed by dr dan
prepared the acid injector and shoved it
into the breech in 096's spine as the
acid was pumped by the gallon into 096's
bones the creature let out the most
horrifying whale it kicked and bucked as
more acid was pumped in melting those
indestructible bones from within the
creature even began to vomit acid as it
panicked melting the bag off of its own
head some panicked and averted their
gaze dr dan
didn't he stared directly at the
creature's face for the first time as it
melted in front of him with nothing
short of pure elation had he won had he
actually won the creature let out a
gurgling shriek and the guards opened
fire their bullets splattered into the
monsters melting flesh and bones as it
hollered and shrieked they didn't let up
firing up and down its body spraying it
with white hot lead it began to melt and
bubble away expanding into a great
gruesome puddle on the floor beneath
them
dr dan laughed like a madman even as the
guards grabbed him and dragged him away
from the foul-smelling greasy mess
bubbling with chemical life he just kept
laughing even though he knew the death
of 096 meant an equally swift death of
his own it didn't matter it had all been
for something the world
was saved it was over he'd finally
won
close your eyes and pray for salvation
we're returning to the lanky lethal lad
whose rampages often result in legendary
losses of life it's
scp-096 the shy guy long time fans of
the channel will no doubt know this
anomalous monster like the back of their
hand after all we have several videos on
the subject that are definitely worth
checking out sometime but to get the
full benefit of today's tale we'll do a
quick refresh for any potential
newcomers in the audience good to have
you here let's start with the basics the
first thing you'll probably notice about
096 is its daunting size and rather
unusual bodily proportions while mostly
humanoid in shape the shy guy has long
dangling arms that almost reach the
ground its body is thin and hairless
with opaque clear white pupillus eyes
and a wide gaping mouth it is a truly
chilling sight to behold an abomination
that conjures up nightmares just to look
at it and we mean that literally you
don't want to look at this thing and
we'll get to why in a moment
scp-096 doesn't really do much during an
average day usually this tall spindly
humanoid entity will spend its downtime
just aimlessly pacing around in its
containment cell and perhaps
occasionally taking a nap pretty
relatable right especially if you've
been trapped in your college dorm room
during the lockdown but if some unlucky
soul should dare to look at scp-096
specifically its horrible face that's
when the monster starts to act very
differently now someone doesn't have to
be directly looking at scp-096 to make
this happen even glancing at a blurry
distorted photo of it or watching
security footage of the creature can
have the same deadly result you see the
moment
scp-096's face is seen the wiry monster
will know when this happens the creature
suffers what appears to be a
psychological meltdown covering its face
with its huge claw-like hands and
weeping hence the nickname shy guy
utterly inconsolable and suffering from
extreme emotional distress eventually
the creature will be unable to take it
anymore standing up
scp-096 will then travel towards whoever
dared to look at it using anomalous
speed to hunt down the person that saw
its face the foundation has proven that
it is unquestionably impossible for
anyone to hide from scp-096
literally nothing can stand in its path
as it tracks down its victim not walls
or locked doors even being aboard a boat
in the middle of the ocean or in a plane
in mid-air can prevent it from finding
you and when it does find you it's not a
pleasant sight
scp-096 will kill the person that looked
at it without leaving any detectable
trace on their body the monster is
impervious to gunfire and all other
forms of conventional weaponry it can't
be killed or even so much as harmed even
if the shy guy is only seen as a tiny
little speck in a photograph this will
be enough to trigger the creature's
relentless defense mechanism so because
of this the scp foundation's only real
way to keep the creature safely locked
up is in an airtight steel cube with no
security cameras or surveillance tools
of any kind all members of personnel are
reminded that they are to never ever
look at it but what if they could what
if somehow someone was able to
neutralize
scp-096's anomalous abilities or was
resistant to being killed when the
creature inevitably tracked them down
this is how the tail known as picture
perfect begins what do you think boys is
she a beauty or what dr klepp proclaimed
to a group of his fellow high-ranking
foundation researchers the group looked
in confusion and unease at what clef had
been referring to namely a photograph
that he just hung up on the wall of his
office a photo of what though well a
four foot by five foot picture of none
other than
scp-096 of course naturally the other
researchers shared a mixture of shock
and dismay at what clef had just done as
you would if one of your co-workers hung
up a photo of a creature that could kill
you just for looking at that said photo
we've lost a number of staff members
from around the scp-explained office
that same way let's just say the
christmas party last year was not that
fun dr klaff had long been one of the
more enigmatic and mysterious scientists
working at the foundation with the
exception of the elusive and infamous o5
council alto clef was formerly an
operative for the global cult coalition
as well as being known to be a bit of a
gun enthusiast and all-around crazy wild
card clef earned his own brand of infamy
for his rumored practice of brutally
decommissioning dangerous scps and you
can probably guess what we mean by that
he's the foundation's go-to executioner
and a specialist in dealing with reality
bending anomalies would you expect any
less from an ex-goc joining clef in his
office were the likes of dr jack bright
another infamous foundation researcher
dr bright also known as
scp-963-2 was assigned to conduct
experiments on an anomalous amulet
scp-963
which resulted in his death at the hands
of scp-076
able however anomalous properties of the
amulet gave bright the ability to
inhabit new bodies after his death
specifically anyone who also touches the
amulet which kills the host and allows
bright to take control of their body
while technically immortal dr bright
isn't exactly stoked about that fact
often seeking out death and wanting to
know exactly what it feels like also
present at the unveiling of dr cliff's
photo of scp-096 was his friendly rival
dr kondraki while usually gruff and
antisocial kondraki is an expert in
perception-based anomalies normally
called upon by the foundation to
photograph scps that would otherwise be
invisible or imperceivable dr sumerian a
member of the foundation's ethics
committee was also in the room as dr
clef proudly showed off his office's
latest decoration perhaps the most
outwardly strange researcher in
attendance was kane pathos crow a
scientist from the foundation's research
department who had been transformed into
a labrador retriever after an experiment
that needless to say went a bit awry
crow must have been barking up the wrong
tree on that one each of them expressed
their reactions differently deeply
exasperated dr sumerian shook his head
and began to question his recent
decision to stop drinking meanwhile dr
bright looked up at the painting with a
bemused tilting of his head he wondered
if scp-096 would come to kill him and if
it did would it only do so once or would
the creature try again and again each
time that bright inhabited a new body
perhaps in an attempt to look away from
the photo kane lowered his head and
covered his snout with a paw while dr
kondraki hung his head in deep
disappointment the only one among the
group that seemed unaffected by the site
of the scp-096 photograph was dr charles
gears another high-ranking scp
foundation scientist it was gears who
finally broke the uncomfortable silence
asking dr cleff the one question that
had been on everyone's minds
why clef excitedly exclaimed that the
photo was meant to be in celebration of
scp-096 finally having been neutralized
and according to the scientists they
were free to look the creature's ugly
mug all they wanted the group stared in
horror at the gaping mouth the screaming
expression of the monster that had
killed so many people not one of them
shared in dr cleff's enthusiasm some
like bright and gear simply argued that
the picture was creepy while others
voiced far greater concerns kane argued
that putting up a photo of scp-096 was
in poor taste that it was massively
disrespectful to all the unwitting
victims that the shy guy had killed over
the years it was also reckless and
dangerous dr sumerian added it had not
yet been a full 24 hours since
scp-096's apparent death and if the
creature was somehow able to come back
to life it could kill every researcher
in the office by showing them this
so-called masterpiece clef had put all
of his co-workers lives at risk he
shugged off their concerns of the
creature coming back to life despite
knowing that this was entirely possible
after all wasn't just anomalies and scps
that could defy death most of the
foundation's higher ranking staff were
also capable of the same even some of
the researchers in that very room had
died at least once dr kleff claimed that
should the worst happen in scp-096
return to life they could simply forget
its face with amnestics clef claimed
that they were now free of
scp-096's anomalous powers thanks to the
creature's termination but the four men
and one dog in his office with him
failed to share his enthusiasm the group
then began debating why the foundation
even needed to neutralize scp-096 in the
first place with its containment purely
hinged on nobody ever looking at the
creature he could be contained by
putting a sack over his head dr bright
pointed out met with murmurs of
agreement from the others that's where
you're wrong jack there could be photos
of him from before he was contained or
someone could get a hold of the photos
we already have of him dr cliff argued
back if they did something like hack
markiplier's youtube account put that
photo on the home page it'd be game over
the shy guy would breach containment
with millions of dash ones to kill all
over the world and that kind of rampage
would guarantee he'd have cameras
pointed on him 24 7. exposure would grow
exponentially until the bastard
slaughtered most of the civilization as
far as i'm concerned he should have been
classified as ketter from the start but
bright argued back stating that the
foundation had no real cause to kill
scp-096
they already had a clear understanding
that the shy guy's anomalous behaviors
were only even triggered by somebody
observing it and preventing that from
happening was pretty easy killing the
creature just seemed excessive cruel
even sumerian chimed in again saying
that killing scp-096 was something the
global occult coalition would do and the
foundation still hadn't learned all they
could about zero nine six could someone
survive looking at the creature if they
were in space or another dimension now
no one would ever know on top of that dr
gears pointed out that the foundation
had no clue what scp-096
exact origin was where the creature had
come from if it was the only one of its
kind or whether it was a part of a
species of similar monsters if more
beings like the shy guy could exist in
the future they could cause a global
catastrophe but despite all the points
raised by his colleagues dr cleff didn't
want to hear any of what they had to say
all right i hear what you're all saying
but shut up the shy guy was a sword of
damocles dangling over the whole world
we killed him and we're gonna celebrate
that by doing the one thing we could
never do while he was alive looking at
his face each and every day for the rest
of our lives so that we never forget
what we've won and could have lost the
four researchers and the one who had
been turned into a dog all took a moment
to consider clef's argument more
courtesy than he had extended to them
they all looked up at the haunting
grotesque face of scp-096 once more as
much as they protested the decision to
have the creature killed each of them
secretly hoped it stayed neutralized
especially now that clef was using
scp-096's photo as an office decoration
if the creature ever managed to come
back anyone that set foot in cleft's
office and looked at the picture was as
good as dead finally dr kondraki spoke
up and threatened to resign cleft to one
of the worst positions imaginable
critiquing first drafts of scp reports
by junior researchers for a moment clef
thought his rival was bluffing but
eventually decided it was better to be
safe than sorry as the gunhow foundation
scientist begrudgingly pulled the photo
from his office wall he muttered to the
group no none of you appreciate
post-modern art a group of well-armed
mobile task force members entered the
containment chamber armed to the teeth
some face the ground droplets of sweat
dripping onto their visors some wore dr
dan's infamous scramble goggles and one
particularly brave member of personnel
wielded only a bag the room they were
currently standing in was perhaps the
most dangerous place in the world why
because it contained two terrifying
titans of the anomalous world
scp-682 the infinitely hateful hard to
destroy reptile and scp-019
the shy guy the ultimate mindless
killing machine and if the very idea of
having them in the same place doesn't
feel risky enough the deadly duo had
just spent 27 hours in one of the most
brutal brawls imaginable and
incidentally fights like this are
exactly why we're here today we cover a
lot of scps on this channel and we've
seen the way some of the most dangerous
anomalies out there can tear their way
through civilians and train foundation
mtf operatives with ease but how do they
fare against monsters maniacs and
reality benders their own size with the
help of the scp-explained audience we're
going to explore theoretical fights
between some of the anomalous world's
biggest badasses and who better to get
this show on the road than two of the
most iconic and deadly monsters that
haunt the halls of a foundation
containment site near you the hard to
destroy reptile and the shy guy are
household names for anyone familiar with
the scp foundation and before we get
into the gruesome results of their first
fight and your theories about how a
potential rematch might play out let's
get to know the combat progress of this
pair of nasty customers what kind of
damage are they capable of taking and
inflicting spoiler alert it's a hell of
a lot in this corner we have
scp-682 a monster whose ability to
survive seemingly anything is only equal
by its terrible attitude towards pretty
much everyone and everything around it
though to be fair you'd probably be a
little grumpy too if the scp foundation
was constantly trying to murder you in
different ways rather than just keeping
you contained 682's basic offensive
power set involves impressive strength
speed intelligence and the aid of its
deadly fangs claws and tail however 682
is considerably stronger after it's just
survived and regenerated from a
termination attempt that's because the
true combat asset of 682 is and always
has been its adaptability specifically
if some kind of attack brings 682 into a
state of near death but doesn't finish
the job 682 will generally either
develop a perfect defense or counter
offensive for that attack or somehow add
a version of the attack to its own
arsenal this has ranged from super
pressurized jets of its own blood
dangerously radioactive banana beams
firing out of its mouth and even an
incapacitating laughter blast gained
from an encounter with the adorable
scp-999
it is an absolute swiss army knife of
dangerous anomalous powers and abilities
and if you need any further proof of
that check out our multiple videos on
all the ludicrous failed attempts to
kill this nightmare lizard and in this
corner we've got
scp-096 the shy guy while 682 is
freakishly adaptable in most situations
scp-096 is pretty much unstoppable this
long gangly creep will murder anyone who
sees even the tiniest glimpse of its
face with such ferocity that not even a
trace of the body will remain it does
this by entering what many call its rage
state activated by the sudden immense
distress of its face being seen when it
enters this state the scp foundation has
only one prerogative get themselves and
anyone else out of its way because you
will not stop this thing until it's
killed its target all the scp foundation
has ever been able to do is wait until
after the target has been obliterated
and then come in to bag its head when it
enters its docile state almost nothing
else has even successfully slowed it
down while they have been capable of
damaging its flesh the monster skeleton
seems to be utterly indestructible and
its damaged flesh has proven
consistently able to grow back the
monster seems to be immune to everything
from pain to cold and moves at such a
speed that it's pretty much impossible
to escape for long so when you factor in
an indestructible body immense strength
immense speed and an unstoppable urge to
kill anyone who sees its face you're
looking at a formidable opponent it's
only natural that the foundation would
want to use 096 in their 682 cross tests
so what exactly happened when the mobile
task force entered the room after this
first epic battle what did they find
inside the chamber in the grisly
aftermath
scp-096 lay crumpled in the corner
wheezing scared covered in its own blood
682 was barely recognizable 096 had
reduced it to a quarter of its original
size the rest having been utterly torn
to shreds both had narrowly survived the
encounter but it was an epic battle
neither of them would ever forget though
this was especially true for scp-096
you see as we alluded to earlier
scp-682 is used to taking a kicking at
this point it hasn't ever truly been
killed but it's been beaten eaten burned
zapped and smashed within an inch of its
life more times than you can count 096
on the other hand was not used to not
being able to utterly eliminate its prey
while it is impossible to speculate
what's going on inside
scp-096's mind all evidence points
towards getting a draw in this battle
seriously damaging
scp-096's confidence now every time
foundation personnel tries to bring 096
into 682's containment chamber he begins
crying and scratching at his own face
why is he scared of 682 is he humiliated
thinking of the fight he wasn't able to
win or is the very idea of someone
seeing his face and him not being able
to immediately kill them just too
unbearably stressful seeing as the shy
guy's mouth is only good for two things
and neither of them are for talking
we'll never truly know but either way
it's clear that 096 has no interest in a
rematch but what if that changed what if
096 realized that it was wasting its
potential it managed to get scp-682
three-quarters of the way to death last
time what could stop it from getting
that last quarter sure nothing has ever
killed scp-682 before but there's a
first time for everything right maybe
096 would have a rocky style training
montage where he rebuilds his confidence
and becomes the underdog he was always
meant to be he'd walk right up to that
big nasty reptile and give him the
rematch of the century what would happen
then now we give the floor to you the
loyal viewers of scp explained here are
some of your thoughts theories and
opinions on a potential historic rematch
between these two creeps
let's get ready to rumble
i really wanted an excuse to say that oh
i really like saying that pingu with an
axe said if 682's adaptability is based
around his ability to develop
countermeasures to any damage inflicted
or in the case of 173 a countermeasure
to the cause of said damage i imagine
682 would turn his skin entirely
reflective causing 096 to see his own
face and the feedback loop would break
his mind
interesting whether this would work is
all dependent on whether scp-096 can
actually see or if it is merely capable
of psychically intuiting when someone
else sees its face if the latter is true
then this particular adaptation wouldn't
do much good for scp-682
random users said if this is after their
first cross-test and they were forced to
interact again they wouldn't attempt to
fight each other i feel like they'd form
a truce and take out the researchers on
site yeah this would be one of the worst
case scenarios whether even the scp
foundation could handle a simultaneous
682 and 096 breach without bringing in
hammer down is an open question rahman
vunken said simple after the first
encounter when 096 stopped attacking 682
682 will grow eyes that filter out 096's
face the next time organic scramble
goggles dr dan would be fuming with
jealousy kubesader said i really want
scp-096 to win so i'm sending him a
blind personal trainer so he can beat
the snot out of scp-682
this is exactly the kind of help
scp-096 needs he's got the rage
endurance and strength with a little
help getting his form and technique in
order he'd be an even more formidable
opponent kyoto rio said i'd like to
imagine 096 after playing with 682 for
so long would try to eat 682 in a vain
attempt to kill it only to gain 682's
abilities and vice versa either of these
options would be horrifying
scp-096 with 682's abilities or 682 with
096's abilities would likely be a truly
perfect killing machine that's
terrifying autumn said what if they just
shared a nice cold drink while playing
mario kart i'm sure 096 would be the
white shy guy character in every race
personally we love this idea and we
think 682 would go for bowser i
personally go for luigi ibrahim timur
said 682 would win eventually it's way
more intelligent adaptive and overall
malicious while 096 acts just on
instinct this is undeniably a good point
what 682 lacks in sheer savagery it
makes up for in its ruthless calculating
intelligence could this give it the edge
over 096 monomoy mukherjee said that
fight would be interesting because both
of them now know how they attack and
what their attacks are nice segway due
to the relatively mindless nature of 096
as far as we're aware it's probably
unable to learn from experience 682
however would have the advantage of
knowing how 096 operates in the second
battle devon smith said as much as i'd
like to see how this would play out i
imagine 096 can't manage more than other
scps have in the past not to downplay
him but he might need some extra friends
to do a whole lot more damage it's
undeniable that going in with tag team
partners would better 096's chances of
taking the lizard down however due to
scp-096's shyness and tendency to kill
everyone and everything that looks at
him he doesn't have many friends looking
to volunteer night tales said 096 will
cry in the corner while 682 starts
attacking it eventually it gets confused
that 096 isn't fighting back after an
hour and begins to adapt to it and
becomes docile forever okay look while
it's unlikely that this would happen
it's certainly nice to imagine isn't it
adam britton said narratively it needs
to conclude with a reason to never try
it again so i'm going to say that 682
will telepathically project the image of
096 into the site staff or the entire
human psycho space
yikes this is a possibility so
terrifying and honestly plausible that
it's making us regret wanting to see
this rematch all together chaos
insurgency said i think 682 would just
think for damn sake just leave me alone
given he's been through more termination
attempts than scp 5031 can count on its
fingers who could blame him for getting
a little frustrated michael porter said
i think that 682 and 096 would take each
other to court for aggravated assault
against the other either one of them
will get sentenced to death and will
unsurprisingly not die or the two team
up to kill the entire courtroom and they
walk out as a new serial killing team
the real question is what kind of
lawyers would represent a pair of
murderous anomalous monsters in court
better call saul ari workman said maybe
if we try being nice to them for once we
can offer them a cup of tea and get them
both a therapist 682 will talk all his
hate away and then realize his
wrongdoing and become an activist and
096 would become very confident about
his face and become a model there
problem solved hey when people strive
towards self-improvement we're all
winners but we don't know if we can say
the same for 682-096
even if this rematch ever did happen
perhaps it'd be just another draw an
unstoppable force against an immovable
object but other matchups may be more
clear-cut what kind of versus battles
would you like to see us cover in the
future what scps would you really love
to see duke it out let us know in the
comments and keep an eye out on the
community posts in order to throw in
your anomalous two cents for our next
versus battle a streak of warm blood
splattered across the snow steam rose
off it as it fizzled into the ice
crystals below the severed leg had just
spurted from lei twitching only a few
inches away torn clean off at the hip
like a broken barbie doll i think it
might have belonged to arthur it wasn't
the first time i'd seen limbs cut off
now i've got a few off myself in my time
yeah don't worry i'm not a serial killer
just a med student we all were i
couldn't say the same for the nightmare
we encountered up in the mountains that
terrible day the thin cold air was laden
with screams mine my friends and that
things all that had done to us all that
it was still doing to us and never once
did it stop shrieking and sobbing at the
top of its lungs like it wasn't even in
control of its actions it didn't want to
do this it just had to the violence was
as inevitable as the sunset i screamed
for kyle snow was coming down thick and
fast a curtain of burning brilliant
white i couldn't see anyone not even
that thing that was killing us the water
in my eyes was starting to freeze up it
was cold so damn cold what the hell was
going on here suddenly a dark shape was
moving towards me through the wall of
falling snow it was human vaguely moving
towards me with frantic speed i tensed
in anticipation when i then saw kyle
emerging from the fog he was splattered
with blood his face red from screaming
and exertion his eyes pleaded for help i
couldn't give him the horror caused my
body to react on autopilot with my eyes
climbing closed in terror all i could do
was open my mouth pointing with a
shaking frostbitten finger and force out
a scream behind you
my words were carried off by the brutal
mountain winds and with the sounds of
mutilation ahead of me all i could
imagine with eyes claimed clothes as i
hit the frozen ground was a long grey
arm emerging from the flurry behind kyle
it's gnarled clawed fingers reaching for
his head it was meant to be the vacation
of a lifetime the kind of thing that you
could only experience once but you'd
never forget we all thought in our own
ways that we'd look back on the photos
with misty eyes when we were all old men
we didn't know that within a week of
arriving in switzerland whether any of
us would even make it to old age would
suddenly become an open question all
four of us were doctors in training even
if you don't know much about the
profession it probably won't surprise
you to hear that there's a lot of
practice and education involved before
you can ever really call yourself a
doctor without feeling like a fraud you
need to ace your sats then slog through
four years of pre-med another four years
of medical school then the better part
of a decade doing your residency seems a
little much i know but believe me you
don't want some cowboy sticking his
hands in your chest cavity without all
the proper training but after we finally
graduated from harvard med my friends
and i decided that we needed a break
before the profession swallowed us back
up again it was me brandon arthur and of
course kyle a lot of people i attended
class with would probably make a tidy
sum over the course of their medical
careers many of them would have made
fine doctors but all of us knew that
kyle molloy was more than that he was
going to be a truly great doctor he was
smart confident driven and had the kind
of smooth effortless charm that made you
just feel safe around him where he went
we followed so naturally when he
suggested we take a week-long sojourn in
switzerland the rest of us were all for
it we expected an easy week of gourmet
cheese fine chocolate and the occasional
jaunt down some old historic districts
the exact kind of relaxing break we
needed after the soul-crushing pressure
of eight years studying the hallowed art
of medicine but of course that wasn't
what kyle had planned for us it turned
out his tastes were far more extreme
than what the rest of us had in mind his
vision of a swiss vacation was mostly
forest hikes backcountry skiing
snowboarding and a little mountaineering
through the swiss alps apparently he'd
spent a good portion of his childhood
taking swiss vacations and wanted to
give us a little slice of his personal
paradise as someone who wasn't exactly
crazy about heights or the cold i can't
pretend i was eager at first but kyle
always found a way of talking us back
around it wasn't long until we were
booking our tickets then sitting on the
plane watching the mountains get bigger
through the window and our feet were on
swiss soil it was a beautiful country
and every bit as cold as i feared but
soon enough the cold would be the
absolute least of our worries as i
glanced over the breathtaking view of
the alps i had no idea of the terrible
nightmare lurking out there hidden in
the dark spaces of those great rocks
something i learned in med school is
that human beings are kind of like
fleshy time bombs their fuse ever
burning when you reach a certain age and
believe me that age is younger than you
think the assassin that will one day
sneak up from within and take your life
is already waiting inside you the
cluster of malformed cells that will one
day turn into an inoperable malignant
tumor the early whispers of the heart
defect that gives your ticker its
planned obsolescence the microscopic
ropes of defective genes that'll one day
turn into alzheimer's or parkinson's in
some cases it's just a matter of whether
you can catch it in time but in just as
many cases there really is nothing you
can do you're just waiting for it to get
you after three days in switzerland we
were suiting up in our thick coats and
climbing boots having no idea that the
same principle applied to us except this
wasn't that nasty little assassin within
it was something outside something that
none of our skills or knowledge could
save us from something very old and very
dangerous we were in fates hands now and
sometimes fate can be cruel kyle was
steaming ahead he didn't just want us to
ascend just any mountain peak he wanted
us to attempt the due for spites the
highest peak of the monterosa massive
and the alps as a whole kyle didn't
think anything less than that would be a
challenge after all this was our once in
a lifetime vacation before we fully
started our residency didn't we want to
make this a truly remarkable experience
and because it was kyle none of us
disagreed we started at the base of the
monterosa and began to rise its lowest
levels barely resembled its frosty peak
over 4 600 feet above we took pictures
of some of the wildlife the grazing
ebexes red deer and chamois arthur had
brought a pamphlet on the local wildlife
back at a tourist friendly mountain
lodge and took great joy in pointing out
the different creatures to us as he saw
them brandon got a good laugh about the
fact that there was a small bird native
to the area known as the nuthatch kyle
forged ahead telling us tales of his
prior conquests the climb gradually
transitioned from calm to gruelling as
we ascended the mountain i could feel
the blisters forming on my feet as the
cold first made my face sting and then
go completely numb arthur still
consulting his pamphlet expressed
excitement to see a marmot when we
finally reached 2000 feet of elevation
brandon started to complain vocally
pouring himself a cup of coffee from his
thermos kyle chastised him for whimping
out already after all he said the
hardest parts were yet to come
oh if only he knew just how right he was
we ascended further feeling the air
thinning in our legs growing exhausted
beneath us i started to resent kyle as
he forged on despite it all how could he
keep going when the rest of us were
faltering it just wasn't fair when the
rest of us needed to take a breather we
could feel the sting of his silent
judgment he was always so damn perfect
we're almost there he kept saying even
though we all knew it wasn't true things
took a turn during one of our rest stops
we heard this strange noise a kind of
pain wailing or keening there was
nothing overtly menacing about it but
somehow just hearing that noise chilled
me deeper than any icy gust of mountain
breeze it's difficult to describe but
that terrible sobbing felt like the
purest distillation of true bottomless
despair i've never heard a more hopeless
and mournful noise referring to his
pamphlet again arthur speculated that
the noise could potentially be a lynx
such creatures were apparently native to
the area and their calls had a bizarrely
human quality to them but somehow deep
down i knew this thing wasn't human and
it wasn't an animal either whatever was
making those noises defied normal
metrics of categorization
to the surprise of no one me least of
all kyle decided to lead the way in the
direction of that awful noise brandon
and arthur followed him closely over the
next tundra getting closer and closer to
the sobbing i hung back a little further
gripped by the profound sense of dread i
didn't want to find out what was making
this noise i knew deep in my guts that
if ever we found out what was making
that noise something terrible would
happen and then moments later it did i
heard kyle gasp for the first time ever
the snow was blinding my view and i
couldn't make out what was actually
happening until arthur ran back toward
my direction and threw the blanket of
white snow and with a voice barely
audible through his trembling said that
there was a long grey creature he said
it was naked and looked kind of human
but definitely was not i could barely
make out what my bodies were doing ahead
of me but from the looks of it it seemed
like kyle was walking closer every cell
my body was screaming no no no no no no
but by that point it was already far too
late for all of us the creature began to
turn perhaps it was raw animal instinct
that saved me but i began to turn two
almost in unison to look away from the
creature i just knew that whatever this
thing was i couldn't bear to see it and
it was at that moment as my body hit the
snow and i forced my eyes closed that
the screaming began first i could
recognize the voices of brandon arthur
and kyle screaming and then something
worse i can only assume it was the
creature itself making the most terrible
racket shrieking moaning sobbing and
then
ripping and tearing blood spattering
across the snow i just cowered and shook
against the ground as a massacre
unfolded behind me i was listening to my
friends die powerless kyle all his
strength and direction stripped away by
terror was snatched by the creature as
freezing snowy wind gave it a cloak i
heard kyle's scream and then never heard
anything from him ever again
soon enough it was quiet once more no
noise save for the howling wind and the
quiet sobbing of the abomination from
the snow i don't know for sure why the
creature spared me but part of me has
always suspected that it was because i
never looked at it i'll forever be
darkly curious as to what the monster
truly looked like but my friends found
out and now i'd never see them again i
wandered through the unforgiving cold
for hours fully expecting that my frozen
body would be found in the alps hours
days or even weeks later i didn't even
care anymore the cold numbed my skin my
limbs and my thoughts at some point a
helicopter descended onto the
mountainside full of men and tactical
gear with insignias i couldn't recognize
they wrapped me in an emergency blanket
and brought me in telling me i required
treatment it all turned ecstatic as we
fluttered away from the mountainside and
all i could think about was the monster
that had taken my friends from me it was
still out there waiting now go check out
scp-096 look at a picture of shy guy in
space the shy guy questions and theories
at scp-096 shy guy escape incident
096-1-8 containment breach for more on
the shy guy that haunts all of our
dreams